Guten Abend.
Hello.
Vielen Dank. Stefan, Weihnachten naht. Du musst mir eine Frage beantworten. Was könnte ich meinem Onkel schenken, der vermutlich unterm Tannenbaum erzählen wird? März ist der geeignete Kanzler.
Ich hab ne Antwort gleich für alle, die das auch betrifft. Wir haben ja sehr wenig ein Absagen gekriegt im Sinne von Stefan Wolfgang. Könnt ihr nochmal mein Kartenangebot retweeten? Ich bin krank. Sind also sehr viele heute, die Weihnachten naht, Krise und Therapie bedürftig, deswegen heute hier sind, obwohl sie eigentlich ins Bett gehören?
Nein, sind alle fit einfach mal.
Gut, alle sind fit. Also Wolfgangs Frage, was mache ich jetzt, wenn ich mich trotzdem gestresst fühle, weil ich vielleicht noch kein Weihnachtsgeschenk habe für Onkel Egon, bei dem ich eh nicht weiß, was soll ich so im März fittisch essen, sagen wir mal, schenken. Wir haben heute Geschenke mitgebracht für euch. Hier liegen ungefähr 60 alten Republiken für alle, die grusame Weihnachten haben wollen, die also rein in den Diskurs, aber muss man es selbst machen. Nein, wir sind eure Dienstleister, ihr könnt einfach das Buch verschenken. Ja, das heißt wir fragen jetzt nicht genauer. Ich habe mir gedacht, 200 Leute sind hier, mindestens 60 haben Bedarf. Also ich möchte keine wieder mit nach Hause nehmen.
Gut. Wir haben heute viel vor. Stefan schreibt noch schnell eine WhatsApp oder ich weiß nicht, was die da machen.
Ich komme in zwei Stunden drauf zurück, was ich hier schreibe.
Okay, ich bin sehr gespannt.
Seid gespannt. Wolfgang weiß auch noch von nicht...
.ist so ein bisschen wie früher bei Viva, oder? Wo man dann noch ein Fax geschrieben hat und fand das ganz toll, dass das dann noch live in der Sendung verlesen werden kann. Wir bleiben erst einmal beim Fernsehen und zwar haben wir uns einiges angesehen, was wir heute Abend präsentieren wollen. Stefan sagt aber zurecht, wir haben uns so an Christian Lindner abgearbeitet, dass wir noch gar nicht mal so richtig seine Verabschiedung gehört haben und sollten das doch tun.
Es ist mir wie Schuppen von den Augen und den Ohren gefallen, als ich dachte, wir brauchen ja Clips für die Cays, die sollen möglichst lustig sein oder andernfalls Stimmungsaufhellend. Und wir haben tatsächlich, obwohl wir schon den November besprochen haben, und dann einen Salon hatten, diesen Clip noch gar nicht gespielt. Und ich möchte daran erinnern, dass wir vor zwei Jahren hier Lindner gehasst haben alle. Vielleicht war jemand da. Wir haben Lindner gehasst. Können wir heute auch, kein Problem. Und vor einem Jahr haben wir das Gaslighting von Christian Lindners Partei erklärt. Was bedeutet, das ist für uns auch so ein Cash-in-Moment. Denn wir sind ja das Vorfeld des Vorfelds. Was bedeutet, dieser Salon ist jetzt auch im Kanzleramt angekommen im November. Und wir beziehen das jetzt auf uns. Ja. Es ist auch unser Erfolg, den wir hier kurz uns nochmal anhören.
Ich habe den Bundespräsidenten soeben um die Entlassung des Bundesministers der Finanzen gebeten. Ich sehe mich zu diesem Schritt gezwungen, um Schaden von unserem Land abzuwenden. Wir brauchen eine handlungsfähige Regierung, die die Kraft hat, die nötigen Entscheidungen für unser Land zu treffen.
Herr Berliner Ampel-Koalition, ist am Ende?
Ist schon sechs Wochen her, aber uuuuh. Und das war es ja noch nicht. Es gibt noch einen zweiten 10 Sekünder, der weltbewegend war. Er hat ja noch seine Entlassungsurkunde bekommen. Wir achten jetzt darauf, es ist bestimmt die kürzeste politische Botschaft, die man überhaupt bekommt, die Verlesung der Urkunde. Und sie ist trotzdem inhaltlicher Quatsch.
Die Verlesung der Urkunde gehört dazu. Im Namen der Bundesrepublik Deutschland entlasse ich den Bundesminister Christian Lindner aus seinem Amt als Bundesminister der Finanzen. Für die dem deutschen Volke geleisteten treuen Dienste spreche ich ihm Dank und Anerkennung aus Berlin, den 7. November 2024, der Bundespräsident und die Unterschrift.
Ja, super Stimmung.
Aber ich meine, das war fast nur Formal. Ja, es gab sozusagen ein frei formulierbaren Satz und der war irgendwas mit die Dienste.
Am deutschen Volke, gegen das deutsche Volke, man weiß es nicht.
Das lassen wir diesen Halbparteien mal durchgehen. Nein, natürlich, das ist nicht unsere Sprechweise. Apropos Sprechweise, wir brauchen eine neue Sprechweise. Wolfgang weiß schon in Ansätzen, ich hab's ihm gerade hinter der Bühne erklärt. Was heißt erklärt? Ich hab's gesagt.
Soll ich es jetzt einfach akzeptieren?
Die Erklärung ist, die Erklärung werdet ihr verstehen, wird gleich ausführlich sein. Wir haben jetzt zwei Jahre lang an Lindner rumgedoktert und er wurde entlassen. Jetzt haben wir zwei Monate Zeit, um ein ähnliches Projekt zu fahren. Es geht nicht mehr um Lindner, dieser Erfolg ist eingeheimst. Jetzt geht's um Markus Söder. Aber nicht hassen, sondern feiern. Markus Söder muss jetzt bejubelt und besungen werden. Wir nehmen uns dafür ein bisschen Zeit.
Hast du zu viel bei Instagram und folgst ihm dort?
Das Problem ist ein bisschen wie folgt. Wir wollen ja nicht zu politisch werden, aber wir verstehen so ungefähr. Schwarz-Grün ist ein relativ erfolgreiches Modell. Also in NRW funktioniert das, in Schleswig-Holstein. Das geht so relativ geräuschlos. Die Leute sind irgendwie zufrieden. Und eigentlich ist ja Habeck windelweich geklopft. Also Merz kann ja mit einer Schwarz-Grün von Habeck angeführten, wie auch immer man dann den kleinen Koalitionspartner so benennt, antreten und sagen, ihr müsst das verstehen, lieber Parteitag, das ist meine Bad Bank. Eigentlich will ich hier Blackrock-mäßig durchgreifen, aber wir können ja nicht ganz, weil diese Grünen und so weiter und so fort. Und Habeck macht ja alles mit, das wissen wir. So und das Einzige, was dieses schwarz-grüne Phantasma, was er gerade sich anbaden noch zerschießen kann, ist Markus Söder. Versteht ihr? Denn die Sachlage, wir gucken selten dahin.
Die Feinde, meines Feindes und so.
Ja, genau. Wir müssen jetzt einmal um die Ecke denken. Denn ihr kennt die Zahl wahrscheinlich nicht, aber in Bayern sieht es gerade so aus. Wir gucken hier den Bayern-Trend November 2024, Sonntagsfrage.
Ja, da liegen ganz schön viele Sorgen in der Luft und das bringt uns gleich zur Sonntagsfrage. Und zwar mit den Gewinnern und Verlierern, Andreas.
Ja, wenn am Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre, dann käme die CSU aktuell auf 45 Prozent. Bei der Bundestagswahl 21, da kamen die Christsozialen auf historisch schlechte 31,7 Prozent. Also das wäre jetzt ein sattes Plus von gut 13 Punkten. Die SPD halbiert sich von 18 auf 9 Prozent.
So, CSU 45 Prozent. Das heißt, irgendwer heimst die gerade für sich ein. Der große Kampf ist, ist es Markus Söder, weil er Chefer in diesem Land ist oder ist es der Bundestrend Merz, der sich trotz Söder auch in Bayern zeigt? Dieses Gerangel findet gerade statt. Und da Merz schon im Kanzlerkandidatenamt ist, müssen wir jetzt diejenigen stärken, der ihm das zerschießt.
Ja.
Und jetzt klären wir wie.
Also du hast den Einfall, dass König Söder dann doch die Bundesrepublik regieren würde oder? Oder zumindest nur so viel Sto-Örfeuer macht, dass eine Koalition zwischen Grünen und Schwarzen unmöglich wird?
Ja, mir würde völlig reichen, wenn das bisherige Modell, das hat ja gut funktioniert. Der Kanzlerkandidat lacht und Söder lacht mit. Und deswegen misslinkt die ganze Wahl. Und am Ende ist es doch wieder eine, naja gut, wir reden jetzt nicht darüber, dass es dann auch nichts gewonnen ist, wenn die SPD regiert. Aber wir haben zumindest mal mehr zu verhindern. Also wir gehen das jetzt durch. Ich gebe euch sozusagen Handreichung. Wie sieht der Tweet aus? Wie sieht das Gespräch am Abend aus bei Opa Egon, der schon ein Söder-Fan ist, um ihn da zu bekräftigen. Söder war gestern bei Markus Lanz. Nicht in der Markus-Lanz-Sendung, sondern 20.15 Uhr gab es ein Jahresrepublik oder sowas. Ich hab es nicht in voller Länge geholt. Ich hab mir nur heute Morgen kurz die Söder-Clips reingezogen. Und wir gehen die mal so durch. Also Markus Söder wird begrüßt und wir machen es bitte alle wie Lanz.
Und da ist ja der bayerische Ministerpräsident und Fast-Kanzlerkandidat der Union, Markus Söder. Herzlich willkommen.
Kommen Sie sehr. Schön, dass Sie da sind.
Ihr könnt variieren, aber das Wort Kanzlerkandidat muss immer mit untergebracht werden. Fast-Kanzlerkandidat, hätte ich gern Kanzlerkandidat, der eigentlich bessere Kanzlerkandidat. Ihr müsst immer wieder dran erinnern, dass die CDU-CSU sich nicht einig ist, dass da jemand ist, der vielleicht im Verdacht besser und so weiter. Also dieser Verdacht muss jetzt genährt werden. Dieses Gespräch gleich am Anfang. Was ist los? Gefällt ja euch nicht. Ich finde, das ist der schönste Mann Deutschlands. Markus Söder ist der besterssehende.
Aber er trägt jetzt auch Rollkragen. Schau mal, wie legerisch. Aber auch ein bisschen intellektuell fast.
Genau so will ich das von euch auch. Nehmt euch ein Beispiel. Wolfgang kennt sich in Mode wirklich aus und selbst Wolfgang hat ihn gelobt. Ihr könnt das auch.
Ich denke jetzt gerade an meinen Onkel, der, wie gesagt, Friedrich Merz gut findet, wegen so Diesel-Verbot, Kippen und so weiter. Wenn ich dem natürlich jetzt komme mit Black Rock und Ungleichheit und Mieten und so, da wird er auch sagen, naja, der hat auch so ein komisches marxistisches Kinderbuch geschrieben. Was will er? Aber wenn ich jetzt einfach sage, Söder, der sagt wenigstens noch, was er denkt, dann wird er vielleicht auch ins Grübeln kommen, sage ich, ja stimmt.
Genau. Und das Gute ist, für sehr viele der Argumentation, also alle, brauchen wir keine Inhalte. Also ihr müsst euch nicht selbst im Weg stehen. Ihr müsst jetzt keinen Verrat an irgendwelchen Überzeugungen oder so. Das kommt ohne Inhalte aus. Also diese Lehre steckt ja in diesem Podcast schon drin. Jedenfalls, den Hass auf Habeck, also ich hab zum so nicht damit gespart, aber man kann ihm noch mal eine Funktion zusätzlich geben, denn umso mehr Hass auf Habeck, umso mehr Lobpreisung für Söder.
Robert Habeck haben Sie noch gesehen?
Beim Rausschweben.
Ja.
Grüßt man sich dann oder wie läuft das?
Er schwebt nur raus. Ich hätte ja hallo, wie geht's?
Sie haben Kontakt gesucht?
Nee.
Was hat der denn eigentlich getan?
Ja gar nichts, aber ich halte ihn nicht für kompetent.
Und das ist ja klar, denn Markus Söder ist ja der Kompetenteste. Also jeder ist im Vergleich zu Markus Söder inkompetenter. Das ist die erste Lärm. Markus Söder, wenn er Sätze baut, Gelegenheiten ergreifen. Okay.
Wir haben uns am Anfang mal unterhalten, wir waren ja so ein Stuhlkreis der Fast-Kanzlerkandidaten. Also er dachte, er sei besser als Frau Baerbock. Ich wusste, ich hätte es auch vielleicht sein können.
Sie waren besser als Armin Laschet.
Nein, aber vielleicht, man weiß es ja nicht so.
Also wir wissen es. Natürlich wäre er besser gewesen als Laschet allemal, aber eben auch als mehr.
Aber wir sehen hier ja auch schon, diese Art der Rhetorik ist ja relativ neu in der deutschen Politik. Also Merkel ist ja selbst jetzt, wo sie sich alles rausnehmen kann, immer noch sehr dezent selbst bei ihrer Märzkritik. Ja, also er muss wohl kompetent sein, wenn er Kandidat geworden ist. Das ist auch das Maximum, was Merkel sich da zutraut. Wir haben ja hier schon einen ganz anderen Modus, der eigentlich dahin führt, dass die Situation an sich, in der man gewisse Formen war, in Frage gestellt wird. Und jetzt sagen manche, ja das ist so wie Trump und das kann man natürlich immer leicht damit verbinden. Ich glaube aber schon, dass es interessant ist, wenn diese Regeln des Spiels gebrochen werden, demaskiert das ja auch automatisch alle anderen. Also nicht nur Söder.
Genau. Ja, also in der Ansicht, Wolfgang du spielst gut mit. Sehr gut, sehr gut. Jetzt für alle, die immer noch zweifeln, Söder, selbst wenn ich die Inhalte aussatiere, ich kann das nicht irgendwie so. Dann, es geht ja auch um Bayern. Dann müsst ihr Bayern geil finden. Einfach Bayern so geil finden, wie Markus Söder Bayern geil findet.
Ja, und dann müssen wir unterhalten und so und dann dachte ich, guck mal mal, gibt man sich eine Chance. War auch in Bayern dann am Anfang. Da hab ich das erste Mal gewundert, da haben wir eine Pressekonferenz gemacht. Wir hatten bei Wind alles Mögliche geändert, auch ganz bewusst. Und dann hat er in der Pressekonferenz 20-mal das Wort Norden, Norden, Norden gesagt. Hab ich gesagt, sie wissen schon, sie sind in Bayern. Also einmal könnten sie sagen, Bayern ist auch nicht so übel. Das war irgendwie nicht möglich.
Ja, euch muss es möglich sein. Bayern ist geil. Ich kann mich an diese Pressekonferenz noch erinnern, die er meinte. Da hat er tatsächlich Habeck Maßregeln dafür, dass Habeck über Landesregierung sagte, wo doch jeder weiß, Markus Söder steht einer Staatsregierung vor.
Ja, das ist der Freistaat Bayern. Wer kommt denn heute Abend, da können wir ein bisschen Licht machen, wer kommt denn heute aus dem Freistaat Bayern? Da melden sich ein paar zögerlich. Manche wollen vielleicht noch nicht mit der CSU assoziiert werden, aber jetzt schon üben.
Ihr seid jetzt Bayern. Was nochmal?
In Nürnberg.
Ihr kommt aus der selben Schule?
Ja toll. Also möglicherweise haben wir hier schon den bald neuen Landesvater von Bayern sitzen.
Und für alle, die das wie eine Verschwörungstheorie klingt, nein auch Markus Söder war an der Schule. Er hat eine Ausbildung genossen. Er ist nicht einfach so Finanzminister geworden von Deutschland demnächst.
Herzlich willkommen in Hesse.
Ja. Nun es ist so.
Hier ist es ja so gelaufen, dass die Grünen sich, eigentlich haben ja die Grünen in Hessen den Habeckkurs gefahren, haben gesagt wir versuchen uns ganz lieb der CDU gegenüber zu verhalten, damit wir auf jeden Fall koalieren können. Dann kommt Boris rein und die macht uns sagt, nein, mit den Grünen lieber nicht. Können wir es als Modell schon sehen, wohin es gehen kann.
Genau. Also Tarek Al-Wazir wurde hier windelweiche kloppt und danach hat Boris rein gesagt, nee, ich nehme die SPD. Die sind noch weicher. Zurück zu Söder, 10 wichtigen und schönen Themen. Söder ist Kanzlerkandidat, wie wir jetzt immer dazu sagen, der Herzen wie auch immer. Oder aber wir drehen das Argument so weit, dass wir sagen, nee, komm, eigentlich bist du schon Kanzler. Nicht so ganz von Deutschland, aber diese bayerische Führungsrolle, ist das nicht auch so ein bisschen, nenn ich ganz so kleine Kanzlerschaft?
Wir haben ja mit einer der leistungsfähigsten Volkswirtschaften in Bayern, die sind glaube ich die sechs größte sogar in ganz Europa. Das war eine, die wäre super.
In Bayern? Meinerlei.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ja, das ist wie mit Kalifornien in den USA.
Genau.
Ja, und da gibt es auch immer die Überlegungen, sollen die sich abspalten, hier nochmal dieses bayerische Selbstbewusstsein.
Die sechs größte Volkswirtschaft Europas.
Ja.
Man erfindet halt Kriterien, aber ihr wisst jetzt, das ist legitimiert, Markus Söder gefällt das. Wenn Markus Söder manchmal so Sprüche macht, einfach mitspielen.
Also ein zu starkes Deutschland will keiner, aber ein führungsloses, ein schweigendes, ein schwaches Deutschland verunsichert den ganzen Kontinent. Und deswegen braucht es einen grundlegenden Richtungswechsel. Und darum sag ich Einigkeit vor Eitelkeit und Friedrich Merz halte ich für kompetent. Ich trau ihm zu, dass er das Land gut fühlen wird.
Aber Sie halten sich doch auch für kompetent oder nicht?
Ja, aber für den Kanzler ist Friedrich Merz jetzt unser Kandidat. Ich unterstütze ihn sehr.
Aber ist er der beste denkbare Unionskandidat?
Er hat auch die Union komplett hinter sich, er hat auch meine Unterstützung.
Was kann Friedrich Merz besser als Sie?
Lanz der Fuchs. So, könnte eine Fangenfrage sein, könnte sogar eine Fangenfrage sein, die Söder durchschaut. Wir überprüfen das jetzt mal. Söder wird jetzt eine Antwort geben auf die Frage, was kann Friedrich Merz besser als Sie? Für uns ist die Übung nicht abzuwarten, was er sagt und uns darüber zu wundern, sondern egal, was er sagt, wir finden das gut. Und wir merken uns das für später, falls wir mal auf Söder treffen und sagen, Sie sind der Allerbeste. Und jetzt hören wir die Aufklärung.
Aber er hätte auch antworten können, ja ich bin zu eitel fürs Abend.
Das hätte er sagen können. Aber so ist er ja nicht. Wir hören jetzt Markus Söders Antwort. Tanzen. Herr Söder, Sie sind der beste Tänzer Deutschlands. Wir müssen jetzt hier die Trump-Schiene fahren. Sie sind einfach ausgezeichnet, außergewöhnlich, der Außerwählte und das Kriterium ist dann Tanz. Er hat sich das jetzt ausgesucht. Wir müssen hier dann mitspielen. Tanzen also. Ah ja, wir lassen uns mal im Gespräch mitfließen. Das sind, er war ja nicht so lange da. Also wir hören das quasi, ich hab uns nichts rausgeschnitten. Also falls ihr adaptiert habt, irgendwie Inhalte oder so. Nein, nein, das Gespräch geht so. Lanz weiß, wie man Söder quält und wir greifen das als Leermaterial auf, um das damit umgedrehten Vorzeichen als Preisung zu machen. Wir hören hier dem Fuchs Lanz zu.
Nein, aber er hat eine andere Erfahrung, hat eine breitere internationale Aufstellung, was ich glaube, gerade im Verhältnis zu Amerika sehr wichtig sein wird.
Bei uns hat er eine breite Erfahrung, er war noch nie in Regierungsverantwortung.
Aber dafür in anderen Verantwortung, die uns ein Land gut tun kann.
Sie sind Ministerpräsident von Bayern.
Ja, das ist der entscheidende Satz, aber wir dürfen nicht...
Der sechs stärksten Volkswirtschaft in Europa.
Genau, eigentlich sind Sie doch Kanzler, oder? Nur wir dürfen jetzt nicht meinen Bilanz, sondern ihr müsst es üben. Sie sind der Ministerpräsident von Bayern. Man muss es fühlen und ernst meinen. Auch darauf muss natürlich reagiert werden. Lanz versucht ihn jetzt weiter so ein bisschen aus der Reserve zu locken. Während wir die Frage hören, überlegen wir schon mal, was wird Markus Söder wohl darauf, würde die Einladung in dieser Art Gespräch annehmen?
Sie sind Ministerpräsident von Bayern. An dem Land, von dem Sie sagen, der bayerische Wähler hat es ganz gerne, wenn wir so eine Mischung sind aus so ein bisschen Monarchie und Anarchie.
Na, wird er das ablehnen als, ne das ist doch vormoderne, wir sind doch Demokraten, oder ist Monarchie der Angelhaken, weißt du, der Köder?
Möglich, ja. König Ludwig II.
Richtig. Du bist sehr belesen, kannst das gleich aufklären. Söder natürlich lässt sich nicht lumpen.
Stimmt, das ist in Bayern ein bisschen so, wir haben das auch bei unserer Koalition abgebildet. Wir sind für den Monarchischen Teil zuständig, die zwei Wähler für den Anarchischen. So ist es halt so ein bisschen, in Bayern ist es ein bisschen anders.
So ist das halt so ein bisschen, eigentlich sind wir König so ein bisschen. Ja. Seid ihr bereit dieses Spiel mitzuspielen, wenn ihr mal auf Söder trefft? Okay. Ich zweifel ja so ein bisschen dran, aber okay. Also bis Februar ist jetzt einfach durchzuhalten. Komplimente, Komplimente, Komplimente.
Grund, warum sie sich sowohl figürlich als auch optisch sonst so Ludwig II immer mehr annähern. Das ist mir aufgefallen in diesem Jahr.
Ja, das ist genau die Frage und wir wissen, wir verdanken König Ludwig die Oper in Bayreuth. Das Festspielhaus in Bayreuth. Also das ist natürlich die große Tat, die Markus Söder noch vollbringen muss, damit wir ihn gänzlich lieben.
Allerdings Ludwig II., ich bin da nicht so ganz belesen, aber hat wohl auch ein paar...
War auch ein bisschen, sagen wir, ein bisschen verhaltensauffällig, auch ein bisschen, vielleicht ein bisschen durchgeknallt auch, aber Markus Söder... Und hat sehr schlechte Zähne im Übergang.
Markus Söder kennt seine Vorbilder, er nimmt sich nur das Beste von Dudelich II.
Beim Ende war Ludwig II ist ja alles auseinandergegangen.
Sie wissen auch, wie das geendet ist.
Ich hab mir immer gedacht, wenn ich immer bei inner Talkshow bin, muss ich irgendwie optisch was gegenhalten.
Ja. Und ist es ihm gelungen? Ja.
Also kündig Ludwig ist ja ins Wasser gegangen am Ende seines Lebens, so weit wollen wir es ja nicht treiben.
Bei Wasser beträufelt höchstens ist diese Haut, um ein bisschen zu stylen. Also auch ganz wichtig, der Bart. Ja und die Figur.
Das ist ja interessant. Das ist ja so eine Rückblicksendung, so schön war 2024 mit Markus Lanz. Und dass da aber der Politiker direkt mal auf seine Figur angesprochen wird.
Ja. Das nenne ich die Figur, das Figürliche.
Das Figürliche, ja. So möchte ich jetzt auch, dass du, wenn du nach meinen Erfolgen im Fitnessstudio fragst, immer das Figürliche abfragst.
Aber es ist nicht alles...
Ich war schon wieder zweimal, die Woche morgen geht es wieder.
Ja, sehr gut, sehr gut. Das ist übrigens der Applaus, der dann auch Markus Söder so entgegengefallen wird.
Ja, genau.
Nicht über den Wolfgang abfeiern, den müsst auch Markus abfeiern. Und wenn ihr ja nicht genau wisst, für was, nehmt doch einfach wirklich sein Bad.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es Ihnen geht, ich finde rasieren ist immer eine wirklich lästige Pflicht.
Ja, unvorstellbar, aber einer wächst so sparsam, da passiert gar nichts.
Das ist bei mir offenkundig anders. Und dann hab ich halt irgendwie mal so ein bisschen rasiert, in Anführungsstrichen. Und dann fanden es irgendwie alle nicht so schlecht. Und dann hab ich so, lass mich mal dran, gefällt mir auch ganz gut.
Ja, das ist natürlich die Koketterie der älteren Männer, dass es die anderen nicht so schlecht fanden und deswegen, na gut, lass ich halt den Bart. Wir kennen alle, Söder postet gern Essen.
Ja.
Da machen wir uns natürlich immer besonders lustig drüber. Das ist ein Fehler, wie ihr mittlerweile, glaub ich, mitgekriegt habt. Wann immer Markus Söder Essen postet, müsst ihr das als Einladung aufgreifen, um jetzt den Stachel in Friedrich Merz Arsch noch so ein bisschen mehr anzuspitzen. Die Angebote sind reichhaltig.
Und da das ja auch eine große weltanschauliche Frage ist, zwischen denen bei uns, den Grünen, die extrem gesund, broccoli fanatisch und kohlrabi mäßig sind und ich ess halt nun mal gern auch mal Fleisch und so, hab mir dann, weil ich gern Fleisch esse, jeder mindestens eine bis zwei Würste jeden Tag unter der Nase gehalten und da kannst du auch nicht widerstehen und hast auch Hunger und dann war es ein bisschen viel und da dachte ich mir, in dem Sommer jetzt nehme ich ein bisschen ab.
Wie haben Sie es geschafft mit gedünstetem Gemüse oder wie machen wir das?
Nein, wie es halt so ist, nur die halbe Schweinshachse.
Aber weiterhin schön fett gegessen, also das ist ganz wichtig, nur weniger. Aber immer weiterhin Fett essen und viel Fleisch.
Ja, du brauchst noch eine gewisse Coachprache.
Sonst wird man grüner.
Du musst deinen Medikamenten Coase-Namen geben.
Ja.
Aber Schweinshachse finde ich für Osempic ein bisschen übertrieben.
Das stimmt, ja.
Aber es funktioniert offenbar, es ist super. Ähm, er wird jetzt nochmal auf seine öffentliche Performance angesprochen. Die hat auch mit Essen zu tun, mit was sonst. Wir müssen jetzt ganz groß denken. Ich habe ja immer empfohlen, schon vor zehn Jahren in der Bundespressekonferenz, nehmt euch doch Trump zum Vorbild oder diese ganzen Influenzer oder wie auch immer. Leute, die es medial schaffen, egal womit. Über Inhalte kann man ja immer noch reden, aber die Methode macht es. Söder hat auch so ein Vorbild und will es aber nicht ganz anerkennen. Also bitte nicht entsprechend vergleichen wie Lanz das jetzt macht.
Sie sind ja der berühmteste bayerische Foodblogger, den ich kenne. Verfolge alles, was Sie machen.
Kennen Sie alle?
Ich kenne Sie fast alle. Haben Sie diese Fotos gesehen? Original Fälschung.
Was ist jetzt das Problem?
Das ist doch jetzt kein Zufall.
Natürlich, McDonalds hat ewig ein... Ich bekenne mich, es tut mir leid. Ich esse auch ab und zu gerne McDonalds.
Dann ist nicht die Frage.
Nein, doch ist das Unterschied.
Warum lassen Sie solche Bilder zu?
Warum soll ich jetzt, weil Trump irgendwo was gemacht hat, soll ich die Freiheit mir nehmen lassen, in Bayern den Hauptsitz von McDonalds zu besuchen?
Aber man sieht hier schon wieder auch dieses traurige Deutschland. Wenn man mal diese beiden Fotos vergleicht, Trump und Söder jeweils bei McDonalds. Bei Trump ist es so, dass wir ihn natürlich ohne Sackhaut zwar sehen, aber mit Hemd, rote Krawatte. Aber in Deutschland ist das natürlich wegen des Gesundheitsamtes nicht möglich, so in die Küche reinzustiefeln. Also muss man so einen Kittel anziehen. Und dadurch ist natürlich die Wirkung schon direkt kaputt, weil Markus Lanz jetzt einfach so aussieht, als würde er sich seinen Gehalter ein bisschen aufbessern wollen. Und das ist ein völlig anderer Effekt. Und da können wir also diese Übertragung nicht machen. Aber diese Volksnähe gefällt mir natürlich gut, da wir ja vor einer Weile im Düsseldorfer Ballett waren. Wir waren im Düsseldorfer Ballett und dann waren wir was trinken und irgendwann in größerer Gruppe kam der große Hunger auf und dann sind wir dort nicht zu McDonald's, sondern zu einem Mitbewerber gegangen, nämlich Burger King. Und dort wurde ich dann erkannt und dann habe ich Selfies im Burger King gemacht. Aber nicht in der Küche.
Ihr könnt euch das nicht vorstellen, wie die Leute gestaunt haben. Samstag, 23.30 Uhr, die Treppe runter. Man will noch schnell rechts raus und es ist ja getümmelt. Und dann, Moment, Moment, das ist Wolfgang im Schmett. Ja, aber ich hab auch Fotos dabei. Jetzt ist es gesagt, ich suche mal noch welche raus.
Aber vielleicht ist das auch schon der erste Schritt für ein politisches Amt bei mir dann doch. Ich würde es ganz über die Bilder machen.
Wir haben jetzt im letzten Clip mit Söder nochmal die Lehre bekommen. Söder preisen, aber ihn nicht auf den Schlips treten. Also er will sich nicht vergleichen mit Trump. Und es geht auch nicht um McDonalds, es geht um die Freiheit, warum soll man sich die nehmen lassen und so weiter. Schweinshackse, Freiheit, Bart, ihr wisst Bescheid. Also bei jeder Gelegenheit, die sich bietet und er ist ja omnipräsent, wenn die Gelegenheit sich nicht bieten, müsst ihr sie euch nehmen, x.com/markussöder. Und dann schreibt er einfach zehn Lobpreisungen unter die neuesten Tweets.
Und am besten alle schon mal Frankisch lernen, das kann helfen.
Genau, das hilft und dann wird das auch nichts mit März. Und dann haben wir alles was davon.
Wir fragen uns natürlich immer, wie können wir das Leben uns angenehmer machen? Und da ist natürlich ein Thema immer wieder Work-Life-Balance. Das ist etwas, was uns alle angeht. Und dann habe ich den Chef von JP Morgan Deutschland in einem Podcast von OMR gehört. Stefan Powalli ist seit Jahrzehnten bei JP Morgan. Das ist also eine sehr, sehr bedeutende Bank, die wichtig ist, wenn man IPOs macht, wenn man große Fusionen anstrebt. Eine Bank, an der man eigentlich nicht vorbeikommt. Und da wird selbstredend hart gearbeitet. Die Einstiegsgehälter, so wurde da so ein bisschen kolportiert, liegen bei etwa 80.000, 90.000 Euro. Also dafür kann man es machen. Aber es wird auch einiges abverlangt. Jedenfalls gibt es dort jetzt auch Veränderungen. Vielleicht sind es die jungen Leute, die nicht mehr den Biss haben. Wir lesen es ja bei LinkedIn rauf und runter. Jedenfalls gibt es da jetzt eine andere Mentalität. Und da hören wir doch mal rein.
Das hab ich bei euch gelesen, im Vorfeld ist mir aufgefallen, dass ihr jetzt irgendwie eine Pencil-freie Zeit definiert. Da dachte ich mir, okay, was ist das denn? Pencils Downface heißt das.
Ja, Pencils Downface, was kann das sein? Also diese freie Zeit. Wir hören mal weiter, was das ist.
Und das heißt, dass man bei euch von Freitag, ich glaube, 18 Uhr bis Samstag um 12 Uhr mor- also mittags, keine Stifte in die Hand nehmen soll, weil ansonsten würden da alle arbeiten und wir reden von sechs Tagen. Normalerweise 8.30 Uhr bis 22 Uhr ist bei euch eher so das normale Verständnis von Arbeiten.
Ist das so?
Noch ein bisschen Verständnis.
Verständnis, ich hab Verständnisfragen.
Work-Life-Balance, man muss auch mal frei haben. Also Freitagabend 18 Uhr sollen die Stifte niedergelegt werden. Aber jetzt war ja interessant die Zeitspanne. Bis Samstag Mittag um 12.
Ich hab trotzdem noch mal eine Frage. Also wenn es bei mir hart auf hart kommt und ich meine echt harte Aufgabe natürlich nicht mir selbst gestellt, sondern fremdgestellt bekomme, dann ist das die, ein Brief zu schreiben. Was bedeutet, ich schreibe den, dann druck ich ihn aus, aber diese Briefmarke kauf ich ja, dann muss ich dich drauf schreiben. Und das ist immer dieses eine Mal im Monat, wo mir auffällt, ich habe keinen Stift in Reichweite. Wie arbeiten die bei Cheapie morgen?
Ich glaube, es ist mehr eine Metapher. Also ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass die werden auch nicht die Aktienpakete ausdrucken und in den Schrank legen, sondern ich denke, sie haben es schon digital. Aber was sollten sie sagen? Laptop-Zuklapp-Tag oder so, das war dann auch komisch. Insofern hat man jetzt also diese Stift-Metapher und Povaldi? Versuch das mal zu erklären.
Also wir haben, muss ich mal sagen, wir haben natürlich viele unterschiedliche Bereiche in dem, was wir machen. Aber auf dem Bereich, auf dem du hinziehst, Philipp, das ist das Investment-Banking, wo nach wie vor sehr, sehr hart gearbeitet wird und auch viele, viele Stunden gearbeitet werden.
Ja, also so richtig wissen wir noch nicht, was los ist. Wir hören mal weiter.
Das, was wir eingezogen haben hier, ist ein Framework, wo man sagt, ja, wir wollen verhindern, dass wir unsere Leute hier zu stark arbeiten lassen. Und wir brauchen irgendwie ein Disziplinarium, um mal zu sagen, ja, Freitagabend ist jetzt mal Schluss, jetzt reicht es mal, jetzt ist mal Feierabend. Wir wollen sicherstellen, dass unsere Leute Work-Life-Balance halten können, zum gewissen Grad, ja, die arbeiten uns hier nach wie vor extrem hoch. Das kann man auch gar nicht schönreden, das ist so. Aber dass man sagt, man braucht gewisse Komfortzonen, die man einhalten will. Und dazu gehört, dass wir versucht haben, eins zu ziehen, dass man insbesondere am Wochenende hier nicht unnötig Schleißen dreht, auf irgendwelchen Marketing-Pitches. Aber wenn unsere Kunden den Live-Deals uns brauchen, sind wir natürlich da und dann wird gearbeitet. Aber wenn es Dinge gibt, die man eigentlich besser vermeiden kann, dann versuche das zu vermeiden.
Also so lustige Runden, in denen man nochmal erklärt bekommt, warum das wirklich ein geniales Start-up ist, das könnte man auch dann zum Beispiel Samstags um 14 Uhr machen, aber nicht jetzt vormittags oder Freitagabend um 21 Uhr. Aber wenn jetzt doch irgendwas ganz Wichtiges ansteht, dann geht natürlich auch Samstagmorgen um 8. Also eigentlich geht es immer nur halt diese unnötigen Schleifen. Die sollen nicht entstehen und die Woche über sieht es wie folgt aus.
Aber es ist schon so, du hast das ja jetzt in den letzten Jahrzehnten quasi mitgemacht, man ist ja normalerweise sechs oder auch sieben Tage im Büro.
Wie ich angefangen hab in meinen ersten Jahren, war das absolut so. Und es war wirklich keine leichte Zeit, das war schon eine harte Schule. Mittlerweile durch die Möglichkeit, also elektronischer, die Leute können viel remote machen und so weiter, ist es schon so, dass am Wochenende, wenn man was machen muss, versucht man das von zu Hause auszumachen.
Aber das heißt nicht, dass man frei hat, ne? Die hat nachgefragt von Westermeyer.
Aber am Wochenende bist du auch schon tätig, also wenn du sagst remote, das heißt nicht jetzt irgendwie, wie man ja manchmal remote auch versteht so, ich bin erreichbar, sondern man ist dann schon wirklich am Start und am Rechner und macht.
Also ich würde sagen nicht jedes Wochenende, ja, aber dass ich mal am Wochenende gar nichts mache, das ist schon lange her. Das ist eben vielleicht mal im Sommer, wo es ein bisschen ruhiger ist oder über die Weihnachtsfeiertage.
Gut. Jetzt reicht uns das eigentlich schon als Information. Ich finde es hochinteressant, das so zu hören, weil wir ja diese Debatte tatsächlich die ganze Zeit bei LinkedIn und vorgetragen von CDU, FDP haben, die Leute arbeiten zu wenig, jetzt schreiben sich auch noch laufend krank und sollte man nicht einfach viel mehr arbeiten, die Arbeitszeiten mehr flexibilisieren und all das. Und man denkt ja dann einfach mal an die Leute, die tatsächlich nicht nur gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit verrichten, sondern diese Arbeit ist auch noch sehr hart, die sie verrichten müssen und denkt sich, wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass das so ausgeblendet wird in diesen ganzen LinkedIn-Debatten? Und ich glaube, wir haben jetzt hier gerade so eine Antwort gehört. Also das ist eine Debatte, die wird geführt von Leuten, die tatsächlich 70, 80 Stunden Wochen haben. Also es ist nicht so, dass die alle nur im Büro von 12 bis Mittag sitzen und dann am Wochenende frei haben und nach, weiß ich nicht, wohin fliegen, um Skiurlaub zu gehen, sondern wir haben tatsächlich hier sehr harte arbeitende Leute. Also das ist ganz gewiss. Die Sache ist nur, das ist ja selbst gewähltes Leid dort, das mit viel Schmerzensgeld versehen wird. Also das war ja eben nur das Einstiegshalt, was ich genannt habe. Man kann dann natürlich sehr schnell auf 200, 400.000 im Jahr kommen. Da muss man dann vielleicht auch schon mal eine Stunde länger machen. Das ist irgendwo verständlich. Wem das was ist und wer sagt, ich wollte zwar eine Familie haben, sie aber nicht allzu oft sehen, ist das natürlich ein tolles Angebot. Aber die Geschichte ist ja, wenn plötzlich diese Leute und mit so Leuten verkehrt ja unser Blackrock-Kanzler Friedrich Merz, aber auch alle anderen, wenn diese Leute den Diskurs über Arbeitszeit bestimmen, dann gucken die natürlich auf jemanden, der Straße fegt, der Regale einräumt, Kinder aufpasst oder sonst was. Die machen ja nur 40 Stunden. Die müssten mal ordentlich wieder ans Arbeiten kommen und dann sind sie auch noch krank. Da ist also einfach eine völlige Verschiebung. Wir haben ja sowieso bei den Talkshows immer festgestellt, eigentlich unterhalten sich da Millionäre untereinander. Zum Teil vermieten sie sich noch gegenseitig die Wohnung, wie bei Christian Lindner und Jens Spahn der Fall. Und hier haben wir eigentlich auch noch mal so ein Diskurs, dass wir natürliches mit Leuten zu tun haben, auch Markus Landse, jemand der wahrscheinlich mehr als 38 Stunden die Woche arbeitet, die tatsächlich sehr viel arbeiten und dann kann man darüber reden, wie viel muss es denn sein und wie gerecht ist das, wie viel die an Gehältern bekommen oder so, ist aber alles gar nicht so wichtig. Ich glaube ganz entscheidend ist da zu erkennen, dass diese Leute tatsächlich ein völlig anderes Verhältnis zur Arbeit haben, weil sie eine solche unglaubliche, sagen wir, Aufwandsentstätigung bis Schmerzensgeldprämie bekommen, so dass sie aber glauben, sie könnten den anderen das aufoktuieren, die aber mit 1700 Netto nach Hause gehen und noch nicht so richtig wissen, ob das in diesem Monat ausreichen wird, da die Miete noch mal gestiegen ist. Und das ist genau dieser Diskurs, den man hier wunderbar beobachten kann. Und da ist es dann tatsächlich jetzt ein Zugewin, wenn die mal einen Freitagabend frei haben und dann nicht noch ein Meeting um 22 Uhr anberaubt bekommen, sondern da dann jetzt selbstbewusst darauf verweisen können, ich bin Samstag ab 13 Uhr wieder für sie zu sprechen. Und da kann man aber eigentlich sehr gut sehen, wohin sich das alles entwickelt, wenn eben nur die oberen 10 Prozent Politik machen für die oberen 10 Prozent.
Bei mir startet ja nächstes Jahr die Olivia.
Was ist das?
Meine virtuelle Assistentin, eine Idee von Hugh Grant, dem Schauspieler, der irgendwann diesen Bedarf abdecken wollte, dass ihm immer Sachen zugeschickt werden, Drehbücher oder so. Der wollte darauf reagieren, aber nicht als er selber, sondern er wollte nur die Botschaft nach außen senden, es liegt jetzt auf seinem Schreibtisch. Also hat er sich einen Fake virtuellen Assistenten ausgedacht, der er selber war, der dann E-Mails schreibt unter dem Motto, ich habe es heute Morgen auf seinen Schreibtisch gelegt, es ist ihm schon ganz nah, er meldet sich.
Ach schön, ja.
Und diese Art von Olivia kann man jetzt im KI-Zeitalter natürlich toll umsetzen. Das wirft ja dann die ganze Definition von Arbeit über den Haufen. Meine eigene ist ja auch, dass ich 5 Uhr morgens aufwache und dann, ich kann nicht mehr schlafen, dann höre ich eine Stunde Podcast und denke um 6, cool, ich habe schon eine Stunde gearbeitet. Nur, ich würde daraus ja kein Ich bin cool ableiten. Denn ich frage mich, wann für diese Leute auch der Groschen fällt und sie feststellen, die Coolness entscheidet sich anhand der Frage, was hat denn das für einen volkswirtschaftlichen Nutzen? So im Sinne von, ja für dich hat das einen Nutzen, so du verdienst irgendwie Geld, wie auch immer. Aber was ist denn jetzt der volkswirtschaftliche Nutzen? Machst du es wirklich nur für dich und dein Einkommen? So. Und mal sehen. Ich denke ja die Arbeitsdefinition wandelt sich gerade entsprechend.
Ich kann es nur hoffen und da ist ja wirklich die Hoffnung, dass gerade auch die Jüngeren, die in solchen Sektoren sind, da eine andere Kultur mit reinbringen. Aber wir sehen doch gerade, dass die Kultur, wo es nur geht, zerschlagen wird. Das treffen wir auch vielleicht noch mal als Thema auf. Aber interessant ist, dass ich mit Leuten gesprochen habe, die sich sehr um Kultur bemühen, die bei Institutionen arbeiten und so. Und wo auch jetzt die Gelder ausgehen und dann haben sie tatsächlich eigentlich schon so eine neoliberale Idee beherzigt und gesagt, gut, dann gehen wir doch an Institutionen wie die Banken, an Unternehmen, die könnten doch was sponsern. Und es ging wirklich um niedrige Beträge, irgendwo 5000 Euro für ein Literaturfestival oder so Geschichten. Und es kamen überall Absagen. Es kam überhaupt gar keine Zugabe. Hin und wieder wird ja auch da gefördert. Das will ich hier nicht leugnen. Aber es war interessant, dass als diese dann mit den Unternehmen ins Gespräch kamen und dann so fanden, ja, aber ist das dann für sie nicht wichtig, dass hier auch was anderes noch stattfindet, Literatur und so. Und dann stellte sich einfach heraus, nein, bei den Leuten ist das nicht wichtig, weil die ja gar keine Freizeitaktivitäten wahrnehmen. Also die gehen vielleicht noch sehr spät in ein Luxusgym oder in den Spa-Bereich oder vielleicht gehen sie den Freitag, den sie dann da frei bekommen, feiern, im Schnee oder mit Schnee. Aber sie werden jedenfalls nicht dann in der Oper oder im Kammerkonzert oder im Theater anzutreffen sein. Ja, die Idioten sind. Nein, es ist wirklich diese Kulturlosigkeit. Und wenn sie dann nichts mehr wissen mit dem ganzen Geld, also wenn sie richtig viel haben, dann fangen sie irgendwann an und werden dann mit 60 oder so Kunstsammler. Weil Kunst natürlich auch wieder eine Wertanlage ist. Man kann sich damit beschäftigen, muss sich aber nicht, man kann es vor allem horten und es verlangt nicht viel Rezeptionszeit und man hat wieder eine Exklusivität. Denn es ist ja für so Leute auch irgendwo ein bisschen demütigend, muss man sich mal vorstellen, die verdienen dann eine halbe Million oder so und dann müssen die einfach neben Leuten in der Oper sitzen, die 38 Stunden arbeiten, die verdienen zwar nur zweieinhalbtausend, aber die konnten sich jetzt auch schon diese Opernkarte leisten. Wo ist da noch die Distinktion? Und daran kann man es eigentlich sehr gut sehen, da kann man es eigentlich sehr gut dran sehen, dass also diese Leute, die eine solche Arbeitsmoral haben, ja auch sehr wenig mit sich selbst anfangen können. Sonst würde man ja tatsächlich sich fragen, ist das eigentlich das, was das Leben lebenswert macht, wenn ich die ganze Zeit im Büro bin und höchstens mal das Glück habe, denselben Kram auch remote zu machen.
Ja, jetzt gibt es ja zwei Auswege, oder was heißt zwei Auswege? Es gibt so einen Ausweg, den haben wir ja häufiger betont, du hast ihn angesprochen, so gegen die particularen Ideologien des Wirtschaftens, die particularen Ideologien des Kulturkonsums zu setzen. Also im Sinne von den Banker oben zum Wein entbringen, weil er unten jemanden auf der Straße sieht, der zwar offensichtlich nichts hat, aber richtig Spaß. Was weiß ich. Man sieht einen 14-jährigen auf dem Skateboard und denkt, Mist, ich wär auch gern mal wieder 14. Ich hätte auch diese Skills wie auch immer. Ich hab das alles verpasst. Und jetzt sitz ich hier in einem Banker Turm und geh 22 Uhr ins Gym oder so.
Ja.
Und jetzt hab ich ja schon gehört an eurem kleinen Zwischenapplaus. Also ich sagte, die Idioten, das war natürlich nur spontan, dass ihr meint, ja genau, also es sind ja irgendwie Idioten. Ich möchte jetzt mal mein particularistisches, aber kulturgetriebenes Interesse hier platzieren im Podcast, also ein Thema mit euch besprechen, von dem ich weiß, dass ich damit Spaß habe, reicht mir völlig. Also ich bin gespannt, ihr könnt ja mir dann im Nachhinein sagen, ob euch das auch interessiert hat. Aber vielleicht habt ihr es mitbekommen, Notre-Dame ist wieder da, war abgebrannt. Ja, das ist natürlich traurig gewesen vor fünf Jahren. Man hat es dann so ein bisschen vergessen in der Pandemie, da war doch was und so. Macron immer noch derselbe Präsident und jetzt ist es wieder da. Und wir sehen hier, man hat sich Mühe gegeben. Das ist nicht nur die Fassade, sondern das ist auch Licht, das ist Show. Wir haben mitbekommen, wer alles zu Gast war bei der Eröffnung, alle außer der Kanzler. Er hatte zwar auch eine Einleitung, hat sie nicht angenommen, finde ich. Größter Fehler in dieser Kanzlerschaft.
Steinmeier war da und hat, glaube ich, in der Begegnung mit Trump, Trump erklärt, wer er ist, aber Trump hat es nicht besonders interessiert. Doch, also kann man sich mal ansehen, die Bilder, wenn die da aufeinander treffen. Ich glaube, es ist so, ich bin das oberste Staat überhaupt.
Ja, aber genau, wenn er es ausgeführt hätte, hätte er irgendwann gesagt, ich bin der Präsident von Deutschland und dann hätte Trump gesagt, wie war es Präsident? Also da ist ja nichts, sozusagen. Der eine ist der Amtsinhaber der Präsidentschaft ohne Inhalt und der andere hat das Amt ohne Inhalt. Das ist so, eigentlich ergänzen die sich ganz gut. Ja. Gut, also Notre Dame wurde eröffnet. Wir lassen uns, ich entschuldige mich dafür, aber der kürzeste Weg ist uns, das Ingo uns das erklärt. Das Wunder, das Wunder von Notre Dame. Ganz kurz, ARD-Tagesthemen.
Der Begriff Auferstehung kommt im kirchlichen Zusammenhang ja nun wahrlich nicht selten vor. Diese ist aber eine besondere, denn das, was heute Abend in Paris gefeiert wurde, das grenzt schon an ein kleines Wunder, zumindest aus baulicher Sicht. In gerade mal fünf Jahren ist die berühmte Kathedrale Notre Dame nach dem verheerenden Brand von 2019 restauriert und wieder aufgebaut worden. Und er strahlt wie Phönix aus der Asche in neuem Glanz.
Also das ist im Grunde der Grundbegriff der Kategorienfehler. Notre Dame erstrahlt, das Wunder, der Aufbau ist gelungen. Also ich meine fünf Jahre um ein Dach zu reparieren ist jetzt für dich nicht ein allzu großes Wunder. Was ist denn hier das Wunder? Also die gehen natürlich in dieser Sendung nicht drauf ein, weshalb wir das wo? Natürlich gleich in der New York Times hören. Aber wir lassen uns vorher noch mal, auch Rituale wurden eingehalten. Man weiß nicht genau, wo sie herkommen, was das soll, was hat der da für einen Stab, der Bischofsstab, was ist denn das für ein Interessteil? Also sieht aus wie Herr der Ringe oder sowas. Die Kostüme kommen ja so aus dem Lego-Film.
Tolkien ist ja katholisch und hat da ja einiges aus der katholischen Liturgie sich einverleift.
Ja, ich jedenfalls hier schon, bevor es quasi losging, restlos fasziniert davon, dass sie es durchziehen. Denn ich habe ja im Podcast schon gesagt, ich habe einen großen Wunsch für Europa, lasst doch die Schlüsseltechnologien Schlüsseltechnologien sein. Ist doch okay, wenn die Amerikaner und die Chinesen das für uns entwickeln. Als Verkäufermarkt sind wir ja groß genug, also die kommen schon bei uns an, die Geräte, müssen die jetzt nicht selber machen. Wir könnten doch das, was wir schon hatten, wieder ins Haben zurückverwandeln durch Aufbau. Wir bauen alles wieder auf.
Museumalisierung.
Genau, Kolosseum, alle, jede einzelne Figur. Wir bieten die schönen Kulissen. Ja genau. Es waren schon immer Kulissen. Das ist ja mein großes Gebet an der Stelle. Es waren schon immer Kulissen. Ob wir jetzt heute Kulissen bauen oder nicht, ist egal. Man muss sich halt mit Leben füllen und das wurde hier getan.
Aber kann man das? Also bevor wir da jetzt gleich zu kommen, ist das möglich, das mit Leben zu füllen? Denn ich gehe zum Beispiel hier durch die Altstadt in Frankfurt, die ist kulissenhaft neu errichtet worden und es ist ja nicht mit Leben gefüllt.
Du hast das Programm ja nicht gelesen.
Sondern es ist ja eher, naja, also es ist nicht mit Leben gefüllt, wenn ich da mich beim Römer bewege.
Ich glaub doch, das ist mit Leben gefüllt.
Das sind irgendwelche sehr generischen Cafés und Menschen machen Fotos davor und wissen glaube ich nicht so genau, ob es Phantasialand ist oder noch Frankfurt.
Lass dich doch nicht trügen vom wilden Schein, sondern es ist ein Gebäudeensemble aus 35 Gebäuden. Jedes einzelne hatte einen eigenen anderen Architekten. Die mussten also erstmal ein echtes Ensemble bilden, bevor sie dann sozusagen gebaut haben. Alle Häuser hatten den Anspruch, wie die alten, aber nicht als Repliken aufzubauen und die neuen Gerätschaften und Betoten zu verwenden. Das sind also alles Passivhäuser und sie werden alle bewohnt. Also da ist durchaus Leben.
Aber den Stil, man hat ja nicht einen neuen Stil für eine neue Zeit gefunden, sondern man hat sich ja orientiert genau am alten Stil, so dass wenn man jetzt flüchtig das sehen würde, denkt, ah ja, alte Häuser. Aber man sieht man ein bisschen genauer hin und merkt, nein, das ist nur alles rekonstruiert.
Das ist nur einfach seine Zeit. Ich würde sagen, die neue Altstadt braucht noch so 30 Jahre, bis sie als die Altstadt geht. Und dann, mal gucken, dann können wir Bilanz ziehen. Wenn die neue Oper aufmacht, in 20 Jahren, dann können wir uns die Altstadt noch mal anschauen unter diesem Gesichtspunkt. Man muss auch Geduld haben, so wie hier. Fünf Jahre Bauzeit für ein Gebäude, das irgendwann 1100 eröffnet wurde. Aber man hat hier die Rituale eingehalten. Also der Bischof starb, der Bischof, alle sind zurecht da. Es wird beleuchtet und bescheint, denn es werden Handlungen vollzogen.
Es ist ein Moment, der unter die Haut geht.
Fühlt ihr es?
Dreimal klopft der Erzbischof mit seinem Bischofsstab an die Tür von Notre Dame. Öffne deine Türen, um uns zu helfen, die Liebe, die Wahrheit, die Gerechtigkeit und den Frieden zu finden.
An dieser Stelle können wir uns schon überlegen, machen wir hier den Fehler, uns darüber lustig zu machen? Zurecht? Ich auch. Weil die Tagesthemen nicht mehr Vermögen, als uns den Ablauf der Veranstaltungen einfach da zu bieten. Die Kirche würde ja nicht sagen, ja, ja, das ist die Liturgie, es beginnt bei A und dann wird es bei Z auf und das war's. Mehr gibt es nicht zu sehen. Sondern nein, eigentlich braucht man ja hier so einen Rolf-Udolf-Eckeberg oder wie er hieß und eine Königshochzeit und dann wird die ganze Geschichte da, wo gerade der Lübbenprogramm ist. Was hat es mit diesem, also da leuchtet die ganze Zeit zum Beispiel dieses Ding da. Was auch immer das ist. Also das ist der Bischofsstahl. Das ist der Bischofsstahl. Aber irgendwas hat es mit dem Kristall auf sich.
Offenbar ist das...
Mit dem leuchtenden Etwas.
So ein Bischofsstahl für die Show.
Ja und die Show war sehr gut, denn die Tore gingen dann auch tatsächlich auf. Wir werden es nicht glauben.
Dann öffnet Erzbischof Uelried das Portal der Kathedrale. Das Kirchenschiff heller, schöner als vor dem Brand. Eine Zeremonie mit mehr als 1500 geladenen Gästen. Und denen, die Notre Dame damals gerettet haben. Stehender Applaus für die Feuerwehrleute, die die Flammen damals löschten.
So, es sind also Leute da und allein ihre Anwesenheit schreibt Geschichte, denn Donald Trumps erster Auslandsbesuch zum Beispiel als Präsident re-elect. Wir haben also einen Ablaufplan und wir haben eben schon so einen Subtext gehört. Ich dachte, das wurde originalgetreu aufgebaut und plötzlich heißt es, es ist heller, es ist sauberer, irgendwas ist anders. Also irgendwas stimmt doch da nicht, ja. Und in dem gehen wir jetzt nach. Wir schauen uns hier nochmal an, dass auch um die Kirche das Leben tobte, trotz Regen.
An der Kathedrale, zahlreiche Besucher, um die Zeremonie auf Bildschirmen zu verfolgen, trotz des starken Regens. Das ist das Herz von Paris, das Herz Frankreichs. Es ist einfach unsere Kirche. Bald können wir wieder hinein. Für uns ist es einfach ein historischer Moment. Ab morgen ist Notre Dame wieder für das Publikum geöffnet.
So, 20 jährige Frauen an einer 5-jährigen Baustelle, an einem 1000-jährigen Gebäude. Und man versucht uns das ganz schmackhaft zu machen, indem man uns die Drohnenbilder zeigt. Ja, das passt natürlich nicht. Wir brauchen hier Erklärungen, die finden wir in den Tagsthemen nicht. Aber wir kriegen sie natürlich im The Daily Podcast bei New York Times. Wir hören ja mal in drei Clips rein. Der Chef Architekturkritiker, der schon lange auf seinen ersten Auftritt in diesem Podcast gewartet hat. Endlich war der Anlass da. Notre Dame war abgebrannt. Also spricht Michael Bobbauer mit ihm, nachdem er nicht bei der Eröffnung oder war vielleicht auch davon berichtet, sondern er war vorher schon mal während der Bautätigkeiten da und hat sich dort ein paar Sachen erklären lassen.
Was ich von den Arbeitern gelernt habe, war, dass jeder Baum, der in den Forsten in Frankreich geschnitten wurde, speziell ausgeschlossen wurde, um die Verwaltungen des Biemens zu verändern.
Er sagt, dass sie das Gegenteil von den Mittelfeld-Karpertieren gemacht haben.
Die Mittelfeld-Karpertiere haben ein Baum gefunden, und dann haben sie mit dem Baum gearbeitet.
Und dann haben sie mit dem Baum gearbeitet, und dann hatten sie einen Baum zu suchen, der sich mit dem Baum befand.
Ich versuche, die Menschen in den Forsten von Frankreich zu sehen, die auf die Bäume schauen und sagen, ah, das hier ist wertvoll von diesem Brems.
Du weißt, François in den Rafters da oben, die Klappdraht. Genau.
Und dann haben die Carpentierer heute, mit den gleichen alten Handtouren, Die Kontur der Bombe, die sich an alle Verwundungen in der Mittelläge befand, war genau das gleiche.
Und das war nicht nur für die Authentizität.
Geht dann ewig so lang weiter, kann man sich anhören, ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant. Also die fünf Jahre Bauzeit bedeuten nicht, dass man da vor Ort irgendwie das Beton so lang austrocknen musste oder sowas, sondern da waren aus dem Dachstuhl Baumstämme zu ersetzen und dann hatte man nachgelesen, ah es gab doch damals diesen Wald, wo die das so gepflanzt hatten extra dafür, also ist man da so hin, kennt man auch aus Venedig mit diesen Holzstählen und so und dann hat man gewusst, welche Baumstammarten man braucht und hat sie gesucht. So wie man den Trümmerhaufen in Dresden erst mal kratografiert hat und man heute noch sieht, ah ja da oben ist noch so ein Alterstein und das ist neuer und da kommt wieder so ein Alter. Also man hat sozusagen so möglichst nah dran nachgebaut.
Siehst du nicht, ich finde es sehr schön, dass du uns jetzt hier mal das Handwerk würdigst und nicht hier schnell schnell wir generieren mal eine Kirche und sollen ein bisschen aussehen wie Notre Dame. Nein.
Deswegen erspare ich dir auch, wie man mit dem Leiter-Scanner vorher schon umzog.
Ich ahne schon, dass da auch Technologie neuere Einsatz haben.
Was das aber bedeutet, also der Technologiehinweis nur insoweit, das ist hier Millimeterarbeit. Also jeder einzelne Schnitzbogen, der da irgendwie nochmal angepasst werden musste.
Siehst du, also ich mein, es ist ja so, wenn man ein solches Gebäude betritt, dann hat das ja so eine besondere Gravität, dann ist es ja so, dass man merkt, es ist ein besonderer Ort. Es ist eben nicht ein Freizeitpark, bei dem man auch sieht, naja das ist schon ganz erstaunlich, was die hier gemacht haben, aber es hat eine andere Kraft, wenn ein solches Handwerk drinsteckt, eine solche Arbeit und solche lesende Stücke dort vorkommen. Und ich glaube, dass man daran sehr gut sehen kann, dass wir gerade jetzt, wo alles so schnell generierbar ist, dass es halbwegs in Ordnung aussieht, also man könnte jetzt auch gleich Notre Dame nach München verpflanzen und noch Söder daneben stellen und dann würde es irgendwie auch passen, aber wir sehen also erst da, wo es diese Gravität hat, da hat es auch diese Wirkung von Präsenz und dann ist es tatsächlich ein Ort, der auch hängen bleibt. Diese ganze AI-Produktion, die wir doch erleben, ist doch wirklich immer nur so flüchtig. Es reicht doch gerade für Einmarschmunzeln bei X oder Instagram und dann ist Schluss.
Genau.
Und da sehen wir, es muss also, wenn es tatsächlich jetzt nicht nur Jahrhunderte alt ist, sondern für die nächsten Jahrhunderte wirken soll, und das ist ja eigentlich der Anspruch immer von Kunst, dann muss es mehr sein als ich prompte Maraschwas.
Genau. Also das Wort Gravität ist ja so eine Art aus Verlegenheit geboren, weil man nicht genau weiß, was man da beschreibt. Ich will es auch mal versuchen. Man besucht einen Ort, von dem man weiß, nicht nur der ist so und so hergestellt, diese Handwerkskunst, diese Materialien, was auch immer, sondern hier waren auch schon andere mit anderen Anliegen. Wie zum Beispiel, mein Name ist Napoleon, ich möchte Kaiser werden. Wo werde ich das? Natürlich in Notre-Dame. Oder ich bin gerade in Paris, ich fahre mal nach Notre-Dame, weil ich habe dann ein Foto von Wolfgang gesehen, ich möchte auch mal da fotografiert werden. Also es kann ja in jeder Richtung. Es ist ein Ort, an dem was passiert ist.
Es ist schön, dass du mich gleich in einem Atemzug mit Napoleon nennst, da weiß ich was das bedeuten soll.
Ja, ich kann dich auch im Atemzug mit Trump nennen, denn es ist ja nun der Ort des ersten offiziellen, man weiß ja gar nicht, Staatsbesuch kann man gar nicht so sagen, an dem Trump in Europa auf Zelensky traf und über Europas Schicksal verhandelt wurde. Also all diese Geschichtsschreibung steckt jetzt auch mit diesem Ort verknüpft. Und jetzt hören wir dasselbe von dem Architekturkritiker, was eben schon in den Tagesthemen besprochen wurde. Man sieht die Kirche und kannte sie von vor dem Brand und stellt fest, aber es ist doch irgendwie anders.
Ich bin interessiert, wenn du von dem Ruf runterkommst und du diese exzellentenachtliche, ehrgeizige, devotierende Erfurt beobachtest, um den Ruf zurückzubekommen, wie es vor 1000 Jahren sah.
Was hast du auf dem Inneren gesehen?
Wahrscheinlich die besten bekannten Portionen von Notre Dame.
Also, du weißt, die Entrance in die Kathedrale war zuerst unbeweidbar.
Erstens war es eine konstruktionsreiche Säule, also waren da Leute, die schweres Wachstum bewegen, und es gab noch viel Schaffeln und Schleif.
Aber ziemlich schnell wurde mir klar, was passiert ist.
Ja, und so geht das ewig weiter, also ihr versteht die Idee. Er kommt da rein und denkt, ist ja einmal der Weichstrup durchgegangen, das ist ja alles. Man muss zum Beispiel, also niemand lebend hat, würde ich sagen, die Frauenkirche gesehen vor dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, der sie heute besucht. Und trotzdem kommt man rein und denkt sich so, dieses Rosa, dieses Licht, da ist ja ein Notausgangsschild, steh ich nicht. Also so richtig mystisch kommt einem das nicht vor. Es ist sozusagen zu blank geputzt. Es ist zu Disney, zu neuer Altstadt für so einen liturgisch wichtigen Raum, der eben auch historisch eine Rolle spielen soll. Wo man sich erinnern soll, aber die Wände sind so sand, also so weggeputzt, als wäre der Tatortreiniger drüber gegangen. Man sieht quasi gar nicht mehr.
Du willst also Patina haben, um ein auswendigeres Erlebnis zu haben. Das ist es ja im Prinzip, das war da Patina oder beim Kölner Dom, der ja auch nicht immer so dunkel war.
Genau, der bringt das mit. Der Deporand ist ja tatsächlich eine andere, denn man wollte eine Originaltreue haben, aber eben nicht visuell. Weil wir als Instagram-Opfer erwarten natürlich, dass es aussieht wie vorher, nur darum ging es ja gar nicht. Wo wurde die Originaltreue und dieser Aufwand, die Bäume zu suchen, das Hand zu schnitzen, das dann zu verputzen, niemand sieht jemals diese Baumstämme. Sie sind ja im Daff verbaut. Die Originaltreue betrifft den Ton der Kirche. Was auch ein Vergnügen war, war, dass das Werk, die digitalen Mappen vor dem Feuer zu machen, die Leute, die es rekonstruieren, die Sound des Kathedrals zu reproduieren. Weil jedes Material, jedes Angle, jede Qualität des Gebäudes jetzt wieder produziert werden könnte.
Einer der Organisten, der dort arbeitet, hat mir das gesagt.
Ein Gebäude wie das ist ein Art Organpipen, hat er gesagt.
Es ist ein Volumen, das eine bestimmte Qualität hat.
Er hat gesagt, D-Major klingt wirklich gut in Notre Dame.
And that is often what you experience when you come in.
It's not just looking at things, it's hearing them.
You feel you're surrounded by a particular sound. Which included not just the way it looked, but the way it felt in the building. So, nachdem ich ja im Podcast darüber sprach, dass ich an der Oper vor allem wichtig finde, dass dort alles handgemacht ist, live stattfindet und nichts aus der elektronischen Reproduktion kommt, habe ich einen Text bekommen, also diesen Lesehinweis von, du kannst mir den Titel bestimmt genau sagen, die Reproduzierbarkeit des Kunstwerks Walter Benjamin oder wer auch immer. Also sozusagen ein Text aus der Zeit, als es dann so das Radio und den Fernsehen gab. Hier haben wir es also mit einer...
Das Kunstwerk im Zeitalter seiner Reproduzierbarkeit.
Genau, genau so.
Walter Benjamin.
Ja und hier haben wir es mit einem Klangkörper zu tun, der originalgetreu nachgebaut wurde, wie zu den Zeiten als Napoleon dort gegründet wurde und vor 500 Jahren und vor 700 Jahren wie Römer. Das entzieht sich komplett jeder, also ja man ist nicht nur mit KI oder sowas, kann dem nichts anhaben, sondern allein eine Aufnahme aus Notre Dame ist eben nicht in Notre Dame sein. Also man muss vor Ort sein. Ansonsten kannst du das Phänomen nicht wahrnehmen.
Das ist ja sowas Merkwürdiges mit der Stimme. Also sie wird von einem Menschen produziert. Sie hat also eine ganz materielle Grundlage, wird aber sobald sie hörbar ist ja immateriell, also verlässt den Mund und wird dann immateriell, schwebt dann im Raum und dann ist die Frage, wie reagiert der Raum auf die Stimme und wie reagieren dann die Menschen, die sich im Raum befinden auf die Stimme? Und das ist natürlich etwas, was nicht ersetzbar, nicht reproduzierbar ist und dieses nicht reproduzierbare, obwohl es eigentlich unsichtbar ist, das scheint so wichtig zu sein für diese besondere Situation, in der man sich einfindet, wenn man etwas erlebt, was man so noch nicht erlebt hat und so ist aber erlebt, dass man sich noch danach wird dran erinnern können. Also ich kann jetzt nicht mit der Kirche da aufwarten, aber zum Beispiel mein Klangerlebnis, das ich damals hatte, als ich als sehr junger Mensch zum ersten Mal im Festspielhaus von Bayreuth war, das besonders klingt, weil der Graben sehr tief ist, man das Orchester nicht sieht, man auf sehr harten Stühlen sitzt, damit nichts geschluckt wird, das ist aber ein Klang, den ich so nicht in einem anderen Opernhaus finde, den gibt es so nur in Bayreuth und das ist glaube ich etwas, was heute, wo so viel generierbar ist, wichtiger denn je ist, genau auf dieses Sounddesign zu achten. Eigentlich das Immaterielle muss da sein. Und wenn ich das noch anmerken darf, wir haben jetzt gerade schon gehört und manches sehen wir ja gar nicht oder es ist dann verdeckt und trotzdem ist es da. Auch das ist eigentlich, wenn du Europa wirklich als Kulisse haben willst oder Europa musialisieren willst, etwas ganz entscheidendes. Man könnte natürlich einfach sagen, ja dann nehmen wir doch die Freizeitpark-Architekten und bitten sie schnell noch das Kolosseum bis Ende des Jahres hochzuziehen oder so und dann würden sie das mit Pappmaschine natürlich hinbekommen. Es ist nicht dasselbe, nicht nur wegen der Schwere des Materials, sondern auch was man nicht sehen kann. Es gibt eine schöne Anekdote. Werner Herzog, der berühmte Filmemacher, hat immer wieder mal in den 70ern mit Henning von Gierke zusammengearbeitet. Das ist ein bildender Künstler, der aber auch Setdesign gemacht hat. Und wenn man sich diese Filme ansieht, ich glaube zu nennen wer da, Nosferatu, da war er glaube ich auch dabei, dann ist es so, dass Henning von Gierke auch in die Schubladen etwas reinlegt. Das heißt, wenn eine Szene in der Küche spielt, dann müssen in den Schubladen der Küchenschränke auch Besteckgläser und alles zu finden sein. Auch wenn in diesem Film die Schubladen und die Schränke niemals geöffnet werden. Erst dann wirkt es tatsächlich. Davon war er zutiefst überzeugt. Und ich glaube, dass das stimmt.
Ja, Steven Spielberg hat beim Drehen von ET jemanden angestellt, der dafür sorgt, dass ET immer mit am Tisch sitzt, wenn die Crew zum Essen geht. Das sollte aufgenommen werden.
Schön, ja.
Also wir haben es hier mit einem Gebäude zu tun, das als Klangkörper Anwesenheit erfordert, wenn man es richtig würdigen möchte. Nun waren Leute anwesend und sie haben eine Darbietung dieses Klangkörpers bekommen. Für mich das Highlight dieses Jahres. Denn wir haben das jetzt beschrieben, um was es hier geht. Eigentlich ist es fast egal, was dort gespielt wird musikalisch, oder? Also halt Kirchenlieder, Kirchengesang, keine Ahnung. Man wird sich schon was gedacht haben. Die Orgel muss ja auch wieder eingeweiht. In dem Fall hat man sich für ein Awakening entschieden. Also die Orgel wurde ja geputzt. Sie ist ja vom Brand nicht außer jetzt von Us und Staub geschädigt worden. Also sie wurde geputzt, wieder einmal komplett zerlegt, wieder hingebaut und musste sozusagen erweckt werden. Und das hat man in diese Veranstaltung eingebaut auf eine Art und Weise, bei der ich beim ersten Mal gucken schon dachte, das haben sie sich nicht wirklich getraut. Dann habe ich es mir nochmal angeschaut und habe gedacht, doch sie haben sich es getraut. Beim dritten Mal konnte ich es dann auch ernsthaft genießen und seit jetzt immer wenn ich es nochmal reingucke finde ich es einfach spektakulär.
Das heißt wir besuchen jetzt nur noch Orgel-Konzerte?
Na warte, das heißt für sehr viele von euch hebt mal die Hand, wer das jetzt nicht zum ersten Mal hört, wer das schon mal gehört hat. Okay alle im Raum, alle im Raum hören das jetzt zum ersten Mal. Ich habe gerade gesagt beim ersten Mal habe ich auch gedacht, also das ist doch krank. Wir hören jetzt diesen dreiminütigen Ausschnitt, eines zwanzigminütigen Ausschnitts. Ich beschreibe kurz die Szenerie. Der Bischof wechselt aus was auch immer er da so insgesamt gemacht hat. Nochmal erklärt, der Präsident hat eine Rede, Pipa Po. Und dann, das sehen wir auch gleich an der Geste, dieses kleine Hütchen, was man religiöserweise aussetzt, heißt Pileolus.
Pileolus.
Pileolus. Pileolus. Glück ist Wolfgang hier, um mich zu korrigieren.
Ja. Wenn wir alles ein bisschen genauer nachlesen, will ich vielleicht einfach mal von Kardinal Ratzinger, der Geist der Liturgie lesen.
Ja, das Wort sehe ich wohl, aber ich brauche eine Aussprache.
Okay.
Ich müsste das Hörbuch hören.
Ja.
Also der Pileolus wird sozusagen abgesetzt. Und er wechselt zur Mitra, das sehen wir auch, sie sieht etwas Herrschaftlicher aus. Er wechselt sozusagen über die Banderole, die den Kopf in den Himmel hebt. Also er ist dann im Zwiegespräch mit Gott, stellvertretend die Orgel. Er lässt das Publikum also links liegen. Wir allerdings wissen, das Publikum sind alle. Es war die Hauptstadt der Welt an diesem Abend. Selbst meine Tochter war in Paris, zufälligerweise. Ich hab sie dann gefragt, habt ihr irgendwas mit Staub? Ja, war die Antwort. Ganz Paris, der Stand, still. Gut, also drei Minuten, lasst euch drauf ein. Wir beginnen mit, ich nehme an, französisch, latein. Das könnt ihr dann selber rausfinden. Und danach geht's ins französische Zivilgespräch mit der Orgel. Ich möchte dazu sagen, die Orgel repräsentiert Gott. Hier werden also nicht irgendwelche weltlichen Noten oder so gespielt, sondern der Organist improvisiert. Ich wünsche viel Spaß.
Wir, die Menschen, die hier in dieser Kathedrale zusammengehe, wollen unsere Stimme zu deinem universalen Gesang.
Und so, dass dieser Song, der dir Gott aufreißt, so dass es dir wertvoll sein kann, wir fragen dich, diesen Organ zu erheben, um ihn zu begleiten, damit unsere Herzen in dem Heiligen Geist mit dir singen können.
In der Name von Christ, Hallod!
Jetzt wird der Pileulus ausgezogen und die Mitra kommt. Und man sieht hier vorne Trump schon ganz zusammengesackt, ja. Zweiter Teil.
Das ging achtmal so hin und her.
Ja, sehr schön.
Das ist einfach spektakulär. Genauso wünsche ich mir die Wiedererweckung des Kolosseums als Ort der Spiele, das Forum Romanum als Ort der politischen Begegnung, genau so.
Immer schön Tutti ziehen und dann auch alles raus.
Ich will, dass wir noch einen zweiten Clip daraus hören. Ich habe das jetzt freikomponiert. Ich habe sozusagen die Bildauswahl leiten lassen. Aus den glaube ich ersten vier oder fünf. Ich habe nicht alle acht in guter Qualität gefunden. Gucken wir nur die Ausschnitte, in denen die Kamera grad ins Publikum geht. Also wir sehen nur das Publikum, wie es da sitzt. Was bedeutet, hier sitzen jetzt einige in der Case, die werden sehen, wenn die Gesichter wechseln. Man kann ja darauf achten, ob man auch hört, wo ich die Schnitte gemacht hab. Oder ob das einfach nur so eine, ich will gar kein Wort dafür jetzt missbrauchen, um diese göttliche Herunterkunft von Klang.
Na ja, man kann sich darüber amüsieren, aber es ist ja tatsächlich die Improvisation erstmal, was sehr existenziell ist in der Musik. Der Jazz lebt sehr stark von der Improvisation. Wir sehen uns ja meistens Sachen an, die nicht improvisiert sind. Vielleicht sind wir schon mal bei einem Pop-Rock-Konzert, wo ein bisschen improvisiert wird, wenn der Gitarristen Solo hinlegt. Aber eigentlich wird das gespielt, was man vorhatte zu spielen. Beim Jazz ist das schon anders häufig zumindest. Es gibt ja die legendären Konzerte zum Beispiel auch von Keith Jarrett, dem Pianisten, der also dort reingeht und schaut, wohin es einen treibt. Und es gibt ja tatsächlich sehr, sehr häufig in Kirchen, auch hier überall zu beobachten und zu besuchen, Orgelkonzerte mit einem Improvisationsanteil bzw. komplett improvisierte Konzerte. Ich hab das schon mehrmals besucht und es ist natürlich nicht alles herausragend oder nicht alles sagt einem, spricht zu einem. Aber es ist wirklich erstaunlich, weil diese Orgel natürlich eine Bandbreite an sich schon durch diese verschiedenen Register, durch all die einzelnen Pfeifen, die man hinzugeschieben kann, dass dort eine Fülle an Musik entsteht, bis hin zu Vogelgezwitscher. Auch sowas können manche Orgeln imitieren, dass man sagen kann, ja es ist ja die Frage, woher kommt das? Also die Improvisation beruht natürlich auf Vorhandenem. Also der, der improvisiert, hat natürlich auch seinen Bach-Intus und seinen Max-Reger und all das. Aber dann kommt hier irgendein Sir Plus. Und das ist ja interessant, was ist das? Und da kann man darüber religiös werden, wenn man dann drüber nachdenkt.
Ja, genau.
Was ist das also jetzt für eine Eingebung, die mich jetzt gerade dazu führt, diese Taste nicht eine andere zu drücken?
Ja, vielleicht ist Improvisation, ich hab's jetzt selber gesagt, aus Verlegenheit. Vielleicht sollte man hier sagen, es ist inspiriert. Denn hier ist ja nicht der Organist am Werk, sondern der Himmel selbst.
Naja, aber wir sehen ja schon jemand, der's ausführt.
Genau. Also es ist das Medium, der Mensch als Medium.
Ja, ja, ja, genau.
Aber ich will nur diesen Punkt machen, wir schauen jetzt in diese Gesichter, bei denen ihr überprüfen könnt, ob sie die Tragweite, ihre Anwesenheit verstehen. Denn es geht nicht um die Musik und die Noten und die Lautstärke und was auch immer, sondern es geht darum, es dort zu hören und zwar egal was, dort zu sein. So beim Awakening der Orgel kann man ausblenden, was gespielt wird, es geht darum, dort zu sein. Wir schauen jetzt in die Gesichter, die wir hier sind und überlegen uns, verstehen die Leute gerade an was für einem tollen Moment sie teilgenommen haben oder.
Jill Biden, die erste Dame, mit Ashley Biden, ihrer Tochter.
Der Bundespräsident in der zweiten Reihe. Und hier hängt einer schon ganz durch, ja.
Nur einer genießt, der Bischof von Paris. Also gab durchaus auch ruhige Momente.
Aber es ist eigentlich sehr schön, dass man die Politiker zwingt, dass sie das jetzt einfach mal sich anhören müssen. Sie können jetzt mal nicht ihren Stuss von sich geben, sondern sie müssen da sitzen, hören jetzt einfach der Urgel zu. Meine Idee wäre, wir haben ja noch sehr viele Kirchen, Gott sei Dank, in Deutschland. Wenn wir es schaffen könnten, alle Spitzenpolitiker morgen zum Acht, nicht in die Messe, aber zumindest zu einem einstündigen Orgelkonzert zu bewegen. Ich glaube, sie würden ganz anders, vielleicht auch demütiger in den Tag standen.
Also wir haben sehr viel über Politiker gesprochen, die nicht in Therapie gehen, obwohl sie eine Reflexion bräuchten. Man könnte ihnen wieder sagen, geh doch zumindest zum Gottesdienst. Und zwar gerade dahin, wo die Botschaft lautet, ach so, sie regieren jetzt hier für vier Jahre, okay, hm. Und dann gibt es erstmal Konzert. Also für mich schlägt das hier, ich will es auch wirklich sagen, zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe. Es ist zum einen die Wiederentdeckung, Wiederentdeckung Europas. Wir haben ja übers Lothar-Dag gesprochen. Und zum anderen ist es auch ein, finde ich, richtiger Umgang mit Donald Trump und anderen Alpha-Knall-Chargen. Denn die kommen jetzt hierher und wollen irgendwie Deals machen. Und wir haben ja den tollen Witz gehört, Europa hat weder Telefonnummer noch Ansprechpartner. Europa ist jetzt diese alten Städten. Also wenn Trump meint, er kommt jetzt hierher, gibt es erstmal 8 Stunden liturgische Öffnung des Besuchs. Dann ein 2-wöchiges Festtagsprogramm, um die Tragweite eines Aufenthalts in Europa zu verstehen. Und ab Tag 15 kann man aber nur für eine Stunde am Tag Politik machen.
Ich glaube, das würde den Modus total verändern und würde uns allen sehr gut tun. Auch Opernhäuser würden sich anbieten. Stattdessen gehen die Politiker am liebsten woanders hin. Und ich habe etwas Schlimmes getan, aber ich will es teilen mit allen. Ich habe mir die komplette Ein-Herz-für-Kinder-Gala im ZDF angesehen.
Diese Veranstaltung geht bis 22 Uhr.
Unsere Veranstaltung, ja, aber diese Veranstaltung dort ging bedeutend länger. Sie dauerte drei Stunden. Übertragen hat das ZDF wie gesagt und organisiert war das Ganze vom Axel Springer-Konzern, von der Bild-Zeitung. Und moderiert hat es, ich glaube die ersten verlassen schon den Saal, nein. Moderiert hat es Johannes B.
Erst spendend.
Johannes B. Kerner, der jetzt hier uns schon mal die Begrüßung liefert.
Aber Wochenende war dann irgendwie, bist du auf dem Tätig? Also wenn du sagst remote.
Oh Moment, die Schrift ist so klein, ich bin in der Zeile voll.
80 deutsche Superstars.
Guten Abend, Andrea Bär.
80 deutsche Superstars. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass wir so viele haben, aber wir hören mal weiter.
Toni Kroos. Katharina Witt. Vicky Leandros. Hazel Brugger. Ralf Schmitz. Semino Rossi.
Ja, wir kennen einige Namen, wenn nicht hat man wahrscheinlich Glück gehabt. Es waren natürlich auch Politiker zu Gast.
Guten Abend auch Katja Epstein. Lisa Paus.
Wir wissen, sie konnte nicht viel für die Kinder rausholen, da hilft es vielleicht auf einer Spendengala zu sein, die ein Herz für Kinder heißt. Möglicherweise kann man also das, was mit Staatsknete nicht möglich war, jetzt mit dem Geld der Bürger direkt tun, die dort anrufen und kräftig spenden. Natürlich unterstützen auch die Prominenten gern so etwas, man wird namentlich genannt, man sitzt im Fernsehen, man ist also wieder wer und kann auch die ganze Familie mitbringen, man wird offenbar bewertet.
Verona, San Diego und Brando Poth.
Und wir wissen, wir haben da einen Minister, wo immer gesagt wurde, toll, wie der sich immer streitet mit der Bildzeitung. Aber irgendwie hat es doch geschafft, dort zu sein.
Karl Lauterbach.
Loser.
Andrea Kaiser.
Marc Keller.
Manuela Schwesig.
Lass mich nur kurz fragen, machst du es für uns einfacher oder komplizierter, dadurch, dass du uns nur Audioclips mitgebracht hast?
Ich mache es eigentlich einfacher, denn man wird natürlich durch diese Bilder abgelenkt. Man muss es sich so vorstellen, man hat Kinder gebeten, sich auf die Bühne zu stellen und ganz euphorisch zu jubeln, während diese 80 Leute alle aufgerufen werden. Ja, also den Kindern wird in Deutschland wirklich viel abverlangt. So, dann werden diese Kinder irgendwie wieder beiseite geschoben und dann sind die Erwachsenen dran. Die Kinder kommen aber nachher nochmal wieder werden.
Weißt du, was mich das erinnert?
An was?
Wenn ich mit meinen Kindern zu André Rieu gehe und wir sitzen so in Reihe 37, die Kids nebeneinander und dann steht André Rieu auf der Bühne und sagt und das nächste Lied ist den Kindern der Welt gewidmet und dann drehen sich fünf Reihen Omas und Opas um vor uns, um sich gegenseitig zu zeigen, da sind Kinder.
Da sitzen sie. Und dann? Und nach deinen Kindern bist du schon der Jüngste?
Nur für euch.
Und wir sollen uns ja auf Inhalte konzentrieren und ich habe ja im letzten Jahr diese wunderbare Weihnachtsgala von Florian Silbereisen mitgebracht. Viele werden sich erinnern, die hatte den Vorteil, dass dort nicht gespendet wurde. Hier geht es also darum, wirklich die Welt zu verbessern und wir müssen uns jetzt klar machen, wir haben jetzt hier mit einem Verlag zu tun, mit dem Springer Verlag, der wie kein anderer die FDP-Linie unterstützt. Stärke, die FDP hat Döpfner noch mal den Bildzeitungsleuten geschrieben.
Um die Ampel zu zerstören.
Um die Ampel zu zerstören. Jeder Vorschlag mehr Kindern zu geben, jeder Vorschlag von Lisa Paus oder was da sonst noch so kam, wurde verrissen in der Bildzeitung und sonstwo. Ulf Poschert hat sich darüber lustig gemacht. Permanent auf Twitter und anderswo. Wir wissen, dass diese Journalisten an der Schuldenbremse genauso festhalten wie Christian Lindner. Wir wissen also um all diese Ideologie und Demagogie, die da stattfindet. Und jetzt kommt man an Weihnachten und sagt Mensch, jetzt machen wir mal unser Herz weit und organisieren diese Gala, die natürlich eine ganz große Werbeveranstaltung ist. Drei Stunden vom öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen ausgerichtet für die Bildzeitung. Es ist eigentlich ein Hohn, dass eine Zeitung, die die ganze Zeit nichts anderes tut, als den Rundfunkbeitrag in Frage zu stellen, die öffentlich-rechtlichen in Frage zu stellen, dann eine solche Bühne baut für den Springer-Konzern, der dort drei Stunden lang seine Dauerwerbesendung abrollen kann.
Wir können jetzt ja kurz zum Reißen. Also die Sendeminute für so eine Sendung und Produktion liegen wahrscheinlich zwischen 5.000 und 8.000 Euro. Bei Wettendars war es immer so besonders teuer.
Ja.
So mit fünfstellig hoch aufwärts. So ein Tatort, wir haben ja dann gesehen, ging auch in die Millionen. Also wir sind hier vielleicht bei einem Plus-Minus-Geschäft am Ende.
Ja. Interessant auch, was leistet jetzt eigentlich Springer?
Wenn Sie ein Euro spenden, geht ein Euro in die Projekte. 10 Euro, 10 Euro, 100 Euro, 100 Euro, gleich welcher Betrag. Denn die Verwaltungskosten, die es bei jeder Hilfsorganisation gibt, werden komplett von der Axel-Springer-SE übernommen. Das ist eine tolle Geste und ein guter Moment, um den Vorsitzenden der Bild-Chefredaktion zu begrüßen, Marion Porn.
Guten Abend, Marion.
An Ihrer Seite die Programmdirektorin des ZDF, Dr. Nadine Wilke. Guten Abend, Nadine. Schön euch hier zu haben.
Programmdirektorin und Bild-Zeitung-Chefredaktion sitzen. Da werden von Johannes Pekan nochmal begrüßt und bedankt dafür, dass sie sich so einsetzen.
Hat Marion Horn auch einen eigenen Einmarsch bekommen oder saß sie da schon und die Kamera hat nur auf sie gezeigt?
Sie saß schon, einen eigenen Einmarsch bekam von den Bildjournalisten. Also wollten ja nur Promis da über die Bühne. Bekamen nur Paul Rondsheimer, der eben...
Weil er als Kriegsreporter ins Kriegsgebiet kam.
Ja, aber er hatte offenbar nur noch ein zu kleines Sacko dabei. Aber naja, wir wollen jetzt mal nicht so sein. Ich hab ja auch hier kein Bildmaterial. Wir werden übrigens später noch ein paar Bilder sehen. Aber wir gehen erst mal ernsthaft an die Sache ran. Denn tatsächlich wird ja dort über etwas berichtet, was tatsächlich der Fall ist. Und wir müssen jetzt gerade diese Berichte sehr ernst nehmen und müssen uns dann immer fragen, ja, welche Handhabe hätten wir da? Wir sind ja jetzt nun alle aufgeklärt im Bezug auf Staatsschulden und, und, und.
Eine Müllhalde in der philippinischen Hafenstadt Cebu. Hier wächst Audrey auf. Die Neunjährige sammelt mit ihren Schwestern Plastikmüll, der sich für ein paar Cent verkaufen lässt.
Es ist wichtig, dass wir auf der Müllkippe arbeiten, da verdienen wir Geld. Wenn die LKWs kommen, dann müssen wir schnell sein, sonst finden wir nichts, was wir verkaufen können.
Ich stehe hier auf einem wabernden Berg aus Müll. Das erste, was einem auffällt, ist dieser stechende Geruch. Unserem Team ist empfohlen worden, hier Gummistiefel zu tragen. Und nachdem ich die Metallreste und die Glasschaben gesehen habe, weiß ich auch warum. Das hier ist der Grund, auf dem viele Kinder leben müssen, um zu überleben.
So, hier wären jetzt die interessanten Fragen zu stellen. Wir wissen aber, wie der Springer-Konzern zum Lieferkettengesetz steht. Und die Grünen inzwischen ja auch. Wie sie jetzt das, was auch sowieso nur ein kleiner Fortschritt gewesen wäre, noch zurückdrehen. Wenn wir uns jetzt fragen würden, wo kommt denn dieser Müll genau her? Den haben ja nicht die Kinder da produziert oder deren Eltern. Dann würden wir wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich lange Wege finden, die irgendwo wieder hier hin beispielsweise führen, nach Deutschland. Wir hören uns an, was die Kinder zu sagen haben.
Audrey, Ninia, vielleicht könnt ihr uns erst mal sagen, wie oft ihr hier herkommt und wonach ihr sucht auf der Müllhalde.
Wir kommen hier jeden Tag her und sammeln Plastik. Manchmal finden wir auch etwas zu essen.
Kommt es oft vor, dass ihr euch verletzt, dass ihr euch wehtut?
Ja, das passiert hier oft.
Die Kinder leben mit ihren Eltern am Rand einer Müllhalde, in einer provisorischen Hütte. Kaum mehr als eine Tasse Reis am Tag kann die Mutter ihren Töchtern bieten.
Ich mache mir große Sorgen.
Thema Entwicklungshilfe. Wir wissen, wie die Bildzeitung dazu steht. Wir wissen, was dort Schlagzeile war in den letzten Monaten, nämlich Entwicklungshilfe. Wir bauen doch eh nur Fahrradwege in Peru. Ja, das waren die Meldungen. Da war nicht, wir brauchen mal paar Milliarden für die Kinder auf den Philippinen. Jetzt hören wir hier von der Schule.
Pater Roberto zeigt mir einen Ort, der Hoffnung und Zukunft verspricht. Diese Vorschule wurde mit der deutschen Aktionsgruppe Kinder in Not e.V. aufgebaut. Hier werden 120 Kinder unterrichtet. Das sind 120 kleine Menschen, die nicht auf der Müllhalde arbeiten, sondern in die Schule gehen dürfen, mit der Chance später einen Beruf zu erlernen. Mein Eindruck ist, die Kinder sind unglaublich fröhlich, die tragen die Uniform mit Stolz und Freude. Und man fragt sich, warum kann nicht jedes Kind auf so eine Schule gehen?
Ja, warum nicht? Und was müsste man ändern, damit das der Fall ist? Naja, was angeboten wird, ist natürlich nur der kleine, individualistische Weg.
Ein Herz für Kinder will den Bau der neuen Schule ermöglichen. Mit ihrer Hilfe. Jetzt gibt es ein weiteres Grundstück. Ein Grundstück, auf dem wir Stein für Stein, Euro für Euro noch eine Schule bauen können, damit Kinder versorgt werden können und die Möglichkeit haben, auf ein besseres Leben.
Bitte spenden Sie jetzt.
Ja schön, wenn die zweite Schule gebaut wird, nur was wir ja gehört haben, die Bedarfe sind so unendlich viel größer als jetzt die Frage, brauchen wir noch eine zweite Schule, sondern die Frage ist, brauchen wir noch eine 500.
Schule.
Das wäre eigentlich die Frage, die zu stellen ist.
Vor allem diese Formulierung, wir haben jetzt ein zweites Grundstück, so als gäbe es nicht genug Grundstücke.
Ja, ja. Es geht natürlich sehr häufig bei dieser Gala auch um seltene Krankheiten, die Kinder haben und da hören wir jetzt mal einen Arzt aus der Forschung, der sich da zu Wort meldet auch in so einer Kurzreportage.
Bei der Forschung seltener Krankheiten sind Ärzte wie Professor Dr. Rosewig auf Spenden angewiesen.
Wenn die Forschung nicht weitergehen würde, dann würde Johnny einfach den Weg laufen, den wir bislang von diesen Patienten kennen. Es ist also ein absoluter Wettlauf gegen die Zeit und es mangelt nur am Geld.
Es mangelt nur an Geld. Also die Frage wäre ja hier, naja, wie bekommt man Geld? Die Antwort...
Ein Herz für Kinder möchte gemeinsam mit der Eva-Louise- und Horst-Köhler-Stiftung die Erforschung der noch unheilbaren Krankheit in Nedams unterstützen. Mit ihrer Spende.
Das heißt, was wir hier erleben, ist wirklich diese große Privatisierung, in dem Sinne wir schieben alles ins Private ab. Also es wird Geld gebraucht für eine richtige und relevante Forschung, die noch in den Kinderschuhen steckt. Und man könnte jetzt natürlich über die Schuldenbremse reden, tut man aber hier bewusst nicht, sondern sagt, liebe Oma Erna, die du zu schaust jetzt gerade, mach deinen Portemonnaie mal locker, damit hier der kleine Junge eine Zukunft hat.
Die Horst-Köhler-Stiftung, also der Horst-Köhler, der als Bundespräsident zurückdreht, weil er für die Lieferketten, wir schießen sie uns frei, für diesen Spruch. Ja.
Und seine Gattin war auch dort. Und Johannes lässt auch Grüße bestellen an Horst.
Könnten die das nicht eigentlich zu Weihnachten mitten im Karneval machen?
Es wäre eigentlich schöner. Vor allen Dingen wäre es auch toll, wenn noch so, hey sind sie der Höner und so, wenn die auch noch mit auf die Bühne kommen.
Oder zu Halloween.
Ja, das ist zwar eher eine Halloween-Veranstaltung, aber Friede Springer war nicht dabei. Zwischenergebnis. Valerie Niehaus. Viele werden sie noch kennen von Verbotene Liebe. Sie hat es auf Sofa geschafft und verkündet den Zwischenstand.
Stopp. Wer kennt sie von Verbotene Liebe? Okay.
Drei Leute.
Dann hab ich nichts gesagt.
Und ich gestehe. Ich bin ja gut vorbereitet. Ich kannte sie auch nicht und hab's heute recherchiert.
Valerie, du hast einen ersten Spenden-Zwischenstand, haben die Kollegen mir gesagt. Zu diesem frühen Zeitpunkt der Sendung ist bereits folgender Betrag zusammengekommen.
Es ist bereits 1.823.507 Euro zusammengekommen.
Schon jetzt. Aber, weitermachen.
Wir haben ja gerade erst angefangen. 1.000 Dank. Wirklich, wie wundervoll.
Ich möchte eine Pointe abmelden. Ich hab die Sendung aber nicht gesehen. Deswegen sag ich jetzt, eine Million Euro für die siebte Sekunde der Sendung, das ist nicht schlecht.
Nee, das ist glaube ich so nach einer dreiviertel Stunde passiert. Dauert noch ein bisschen. Wir kommen aber jetzt zu größeren Spendern, nämlich Fußball-Ex-Profi, das hätte jetzt aufgehört. Toni Kroos war zu Gast mit seinem Sohn. Und dieses Sohn ist ein ganz großer Fan dieser Sendung, wie wir jetzt gleich glauben sollen.
Toni Kroos, zu Gast bei Ein Herz für Kinder.
Ich komm schon alles an.
Ich setz dich zu euch. Ich mach mich mal breit in der Mitte. Apropos Ein Herz für Kinder, du hast deinen Sohn mitgebracht.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also der war schon viele Jahre großer Fan dieser Sendung. Und jetzt haben wir es mal geschafft, zusammen herzukommen, aufgrund der Einladung von dir selbstverständlich. Und deswegen habe ich ihn mitgebracht, ja.
Okay, Leon, schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo.
Geht gut?
Ja.
Und du hast wirklich immer Ein Herz für Kinder gerne geguckt?
Ja, jeden Abend.
Immer, wenn das war?
Wow.
Jeden Abend. Wir können ja so froh sein, dass die Sendung nur einmal im Jahr kommt, dass man immer nur einen Abend im Jahr sich dafür freinehmen muss.
Aber wie alt ist der, dass der schon viele Jahre diese Sendung verfolgt?
Wie alt wird der sein? 8 Jahre oder so, hätte ich gedacht.
Da sind drei auch viele Jahre.
Ja. Wir hören jetzt was über seine Stiftung, auch das wieder interessant.
Das Ziel der Toni-Kroos-Stiftung, unbürokratische und schnelle Hilfe dort leisten, wo erkrankte Kinder dringend Hilfsmittel und Therapien brauchen. Da sein, wo Pflege oder Krankenkassen keinen finanziellen Beistand leisten.
Welche Politik macht die Bild-Zeitung? Eine, die versucht, alle Leute, die in Krankenkassen sind, denen noch weniger Möglichkeiten zu bieten, dass sie alles schön privat bezahlen müssen. Und dann kommt man einmal im Jahr daher und sagt, der Toni Kroos hat mal das Potmonet aufgemacht. Hier können wir ein bisschen das kompensieren. Also es ist wirklich der reinste Wahnsinn. Also es geht ja hier gar nicht darüber zu diskutieren, inwieweit Charity sinnvoll ist oder sonst was. Und es ist ja in vielen gezielt Dingen, die man unterstützen kann, tatsächlich gut, dass es das gibt. Aber hier ist ja einfach so was, wir hauen den Start kurz und klein und werfen dann ein paar Euro hinterher. Also das ist wirklich, ich brenne Notre Dame ab, spende aber einen Feuerlöcher. Also das ist ja Wahnsinn. Und Toni Kroos versteht sich da auch als jemand, der ja die Ungleichheit bekämpft. Also Superreiche sind ja dein großes Thema. Hier ist das ein Vorbild, würde ich dich mal fragen.
Toni Kroos, Lichtgestalt des Fußballs, nahbarer Held für Kinder.
Ich glaube, es ist unfassbar wichtig, dass wir uns sozial engagieren, weil ich glaube, dass wir einfach ein gewisses Gleichgewicht herstellen müssen zwischen Menschen, denen es gut geht, die dieses Glück haben, unter anderem so wie ich und den Menschen, die eben ganz schwierige Startvoraussetzungen haben für das Leben.
Also ich habe Mario Götze im Ohr, wie er in deinem Lieblings-Podcast OMR mit diesem Westfalen seine Anlage und Investmentstrategie beschreibt. Die können wir eigentlich nächste Woche im Podcast spielen, den Clip. Und der lässt mich daran zweifeln, ob ich richtig liege damit keine Milliardäre. Vielleicht ist es auch keine Millionäre.
Möglicherweise, ja. Und es ist ja so interessant, also wenn man diesen Ausgleich ja schaffen will, dann würde ich sagen, ach, warum sich jetzt so viel Mühe geben, da rumhampeln in der Bildzeitungsgala. Wir könnten es einfach mit Steuern machen. Also wenn man gerne den Ausgleich will, den will er ja wohl, dann können wir einfach einmal den großen Hebel bedienen, dann wäre man ja fertig. Aber das ist ja nicht gewollt, sondern man muss ja sich dann so exponieren können. Nun ist es so, dass die Bildzeitung es ja versteht, auch die jungen Creator aus dem Netz herzuholen. So zum Beispiel ein TikTok-Star, bei dem wir mal uns fragen können, wie viele Follower hat er eigentlich?
Noelle Goes Crazy, seine Tanzvideos sehen 10 Millionen Follower. Schön, dich zu sehen.
Freut mich auch.
Ja, da kann ich das Mikro mal benutzen. Was hast du für Geschichten schon gehört heute Abend?
200 Euro, 1000 Euro.
1000 Euro?
1000 hatte ich schon auch, ja.
Wow, und die Leute sind ja wahnsinnig spendierfreudig.
Auf jeden Fall, ich bin sehr begeistert und es macht auf jeden Fall Spaß.
Ist ganz toll, dich hier zu haben, ist dein erster Auftritt bei Einherz für Kinder.
Mein erster Auftritt, mein erster Auftritt.
Und du bist immer sehr, sehr herzlich willkommen. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Freut mich sehr, vielen Dank.
Noelle Goes Crazy, 10 Millionen Follower.
Das ist einfach die neue Beherrung. Man sagt einfach 10 Millionen Follower, dann muss es schon gut sein.
Warum ist das über Telefonen? Das verstehe ich irgendwie nicht. Also die rufen dann an?
Ja, du fragst dich warum. Du telefonierst ja nicht gerne. Du bist ja schon erschrocken, wenn ich mal anrufe. Und das passiert ja auch nur alle halbe Jahre, wenn ich im Stau stehe. Ja, hallo.
Na ja, aber das ist ja auch die Schuld.
Du bist jetzt wirklich nicht qualifiziert.
Es hätte ja auch ein Anruf sein können, in dem es dann für mich heißt, ich muss Powerpoint Karaoke mit diesem Kram hier machen.
Ach so.
Hätte ja sonst was sein können. Ich komme heute nicht.
Ich hab die Clips geguckt, dann mach du das bitte.
Ja, ja. Es ist ja so, dass es ein Anreiz sein soll, dass wenn man jetzt 50 Euro spenden will, dass man dort anruft und dann möglicherweise nicht jemand aus der Hotline hat, sondern dass dann ein Prominenter zum Beispiel, wie hieß sie, Ballerini-Haus, dass man nochmal sagen kann, wie hieß sie in der Serie, Frau von Anstetten, Frau von Anstetten, wie geht's denn? Oder Jürgen von der Lippe sitzt auch da. Oder kannst du auch mal anrufen können, Frank Thelen. Konntest du auch mitsprechen?
Weiß ja, was ein Telefon ist.
Der ist sehr eng mit der Telekom, hab ich gehört. Insofern glaube ich schon, dass der das weiß. Die Telekom ist natürlich auch.
Der hat sich bestimmt schon so einen Elon Musk Skylink dahinbauen lassen.
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Nun ist es ja so, dass Firmen auch spendabel sind, wenn es eine Werbewirksamkeit hat. Wir hören uns mal ein Beispiel an. Das wird jetzt von Kindern moderiert. Das ist jetzt die Kindernachricht.
Und wo es lang geht, das zeigt uns Lea. Hier kommt schon die erste gute Meldung. Mats Aach, das ist Bavara. Im Hauptsitz von Niedel auf der Suche nach der perfekten Nudel. Versteckt sie sich nur. Nämlich die Nudel. Bei der Pro Packung 50 Cent an ein Herz für Kinder gespendet werden. Laut Ermittlungen müssten das Ganze 250.000 Euro sein.
So sieht's aus.
Hier wird sie entwickelt, probiert und verbessert.
Ja, 35 Werbesekunden im ZDF. Samstagsabend, wo es normalerweise keine Werbung gibt, das für 250.000 Euro plus natürlich repräsentiert in der BILD-Zeitung, in den sozialen Medien und noch absetzbar. Also besser kann man doch eigentlich nicht rauskommen. Und sowieso ist die Spende ja nur generiert dadurch, dass man da irgendwelche Produkte 50 Cent teurer angeboten hat. Ähnliches Prinzip verfolgt wohl auch LIND.
Bei jedem verkauften Weihnachtsmann spendet LIND und sprünglich Deutschland 20 Cent an ein Herz für Kinder.
Da kommt bestimmt einiges zusammen, oder?
Auf jeden Fall.
Ja, auf Wiederlust kam die Schweiz.
Aber wir brauchen jetzt auch so eine Strategie. Ich sehe schon Lagernation nächstes Jahr dort mit Sitzen.
Meinst du?
Ja.
Ja, das könnte natürlich sein. Also wir disqualifizieren uns jetzt, glaube ich, gerade hier.
Na, ist schade.
Das liegt auch mal am Telefon, Sitze. Naja, wir werden, also es ist ja echt eine larme Sendung. Es passiert fast nicht.
Sie muss sie dann eben entsprechend aufmischen.
Wenn wir jetzt mal über diese Beträge nachdenken, also man sieht eigentlich die Perversität des gegenwärtigen Kapitalismus ja sehr genau an dem, was da gesagt wird. Also das Interessante an dieser Gala ist ja tatsächlich, dass die Missstände in der Welt zum Teil in klarster Klarheit benannt werden, so wie wir das selten hören für ein Massenpublikum. Natürlich gibt es sowas wie Wochenspiegel oder Weltspiegel und so was. Aber hier sieht man und hört man es ganz klar ist auch mit einer entsprechenden Emotionalität unterlegt. Also niemand kann sich hier wegducken und sagen ich hab es ja nicht gewusst. Das Interessante ist aber, dass es nicht verbunden wird mit einer irgendwie gearteten politischen Analyse, sondern das einzige was man anbietet ist immer nur das Individuum zu adressieren, hier spende doch mal was. Und wir sehen das hier dann an solch wirklich ganz drastischen Fällen. Wir sind in Burundi.
Das sind diese Erdnusspassen, drei Stück. Robert wie teuer?
Das kostet ein Euro und das ist eine Tagesration, damit können wir ein Kind behandeln.
Ein Herz für Kinder will die Arbeit von UNICEF im ärmsten Land der Welt unterstützen. Es braucht nur einen Euro am Tag, um ein mangelernährtes Kind zu retten. Wir alle dürfen die Folgen nicht übersehen von Hunger, von Unterernährung und wir könnten einer ganzen Generation Zukunft schenken. Drei Ernährungsfäckchen, die kosten ein Euro.
Also wir sprechen hier von einem Euro, die aufgewendet werden müssen für ein solch unterernährtes Kind. Es gibt in Burundi natürlich sehr, sehr viele Kinder, fünf, sechs Millionen Minderjährige wahrscheinlich oder sieben Millionen. Und man sieht also hier mit wie kleinen Summen dort überleben gerettet werden könnte. Was hier nicht erwähnt wird ist, dass Deutschland noch übrigens interessanterweise unter Entwicklungsminister Müller entschieden hat, keine Entwicklungshilfe mehr nach Burundi zu geben. Gründe sind ja die politische Organisation dort, Korruption und alles mögliche. Mag sein, dass da auch Geld veruntreut wurde und sowas. Aber tatsächlich geht jetzt also nur noch indirekt über einige Hilfswerke, irgendetwas nach Burundi. Und wir könnten natürlich jetzt ohne weiteres aus dem Stand diese Kinder alle ja ernähren. Ohne dass wir das in Deutschland irgendwie merken würden, dass wir das tun. Der Bundeshaushalt ließe das ja her, selbst wenn man bei der Schuldenbremse bleibt. Und das ist die Situation, in der wir da sind. Oder gehen wir nach Tansania, wo sehr viele Kinder aufgrund der Verhältnisse an grauen Stahl erleiden.
Dr. Philippin ist bei uns zu Gast. Schön, dass Sie da sind. Herr Philippin, wie viele kleinen Kindern in Tansania haben Sie schon helfen können? Sie selbst, aber auch die Ärztinnen und Ärzte, die Sie ausgebildet haben.
In den ersten Jahren habe ich selber ein paar hundert operiert, aber dann eben bald tansanische Kollegen eingelernt, insgesamt als Team im Laufe der Jahre ein paar tausend dann.
Ein paar tausend Kinder, denen einfach das Schicksalerblindung erspart bleibt. Was kostet eine solche Operation?
Das ist nicht wenig Geld, aber verhältnismäßig doch günstig 125 Euro.
Also die gesamte OP 125 Euro.
Mit vollen Akkuse bei Kindern.
Okay, das heißt, wenn jemand 25 Euro geben kann, dann brauchen wir fünf, dann haben wir zusammen 125 Euro, dann wäre eine weitere Operation sozusagen gewährleistet.
Also hier wird gesagt, das ist nicht ganz billig. Das ist wahnsinnig billig. Wir sprechen von paar tausend Kindern im Jahr 125 Euro. Wenn man jetzt nur einmal den CEO Döpfner, der Springer AG, ordentlich besteuern würde, könnte man dann mit allen Kindern, die es nötig haben in Tansania, so eine graue Staroperation bezahlen und niemand müsste noch was spenden. In einer solchen verrückten Situation sind wir. Kommen wir nach Deutschland, da ist es jetzt nochmal besonders absurd, denn wir haben diesen Podcast über kaum ein anderes Thema so ausführlich gesprochen wie die Schuldenbremse und wissen, was das für die Kommunen und Städte und alles bedeutet. Thema jetzt auch, ohne dass es Thema ist, hier in der Bildgala.
Es gibt immer mehr Kinder in Deutschland, die nicht schwimmen können. Woran liegt das? Also es gibt wenig Schwimmkurse. Wenn es die gibt, sind die manchmal ganz schön teuer und traurige Nachricht, immer mehr Schwimmbäder schließen.
Ja warum schließen die denn eigentlich? Haben die Lust mehr, ist das Wasser ausgegangen? Wir hören uns jetzt an, hier eine wirklich sehr engagierte Frau, die diese Schwimmkurse gibt.
Aber es gibt Menschen, die versuchen dagegen anzukämpfen, so wie eine Grundschullehrerin in Hamburg-Harburg südlich der Elbe. Juliane Eiseler heißt die Frau, die ehrenamtlich und mit viel Aufwand und sehr viel Engagement mit ihrem Team gemeinsam hilft, diesem Trend entgegenzuwirken.
Alle vier Tage schließt in Deutschland ein Schwimmbad. Die Folge, seit 2020 hat sich die Zahl der nicht schwimmenden Kinder verdoppelt. Juliane Eiseler aus Hamburg hält dagegen. Mit ihrem eigenen Verein Yes We Swim organisiert die Grundschullehrerin Schwimmkurse für Kinder.
Die Nachricht, dass alle vier Tage ein Schwimmbad schließt, ist so eine Naturgegebenheit, aber es gibt jetzt eine Aufrechte. Wenn wir die jetzt unterstützen, haben wir wenigstens noch unser Werk getan. Es ist absurd, auch wenn wir jetzt hören, wie viel Engagement da ist und wenn man weiß, diese Schwimmbad, die geschlossen wurden, hatten auch engagierte Leute, da haben auch Leute freiwillige Schwimmkursen, alles angeboten. Du bist ja jemand, der im Schwimmverein tätig ist. Du weißt ja jetzt, wovon wir hier sprechen.
Jeden Montag wird bei mir geschwommen.
Sehr gut. Und mein Lieber, ich schwimme dir wahrscheinlich davon, denn ich habe nicht nur Seepferdchen, ich habe nicht nur Freischwimmer, Bronze, Silber, sondern auch das Goldabzeichen.
Ihr erlebt mich immer zurückhaltend, klein, laut, humble, demütig. Aber eins kann ich sagen, ich schwimm's mir nie davon.
Okay, also irgendwann wird es diesen Wettbewerb gehen. Ich muss erst noch ein bisschen im Fitnessstudio, dann noch ein bisschen proben. Okay.
Übrigens, ich würde dich drauf festnageln. Du hast es gesagt, irgendwann wird es dazu kommen.
Ich sehe schon jetzt, wie so Bilder mir geschickt werden mit zwanziger Jahre Männerbadeanzügen.
Jedes Kind kann bei Juliane im Verein mit eigenem Tempo schwimmen lernen. Bedürftige Kinder bekommen den Unterricht sogar kostenlos.
Was unterscheidet euer Projekt von anderen Schwimmvereinen und Angeboten, die es ja gibt?
Es ist kostengünstig. Die Kinder dürfen nicht so lange bei uns bleiben, bis sie sich abzeichnen in der Hand haben.
Also das ist ja besonders perfide. Was unterscheidet euren geilen Schwimmverein von den anderen scheiß Schwimmvereinen? Oder was ist hier die Ansage?
Es ist einfach, dass sie das anbietet für so gut wie kein Geld, weil das offenbar ein Problem ist, dass man eine Selbstverständlichkeit in Deutschland nicht ordentlich finanzieren kann und darauf warten muss, dass jemand, die eigentlich auch schon genug zu tun hat, dann sowas noch macht.
Ich hab einen Vorschlag. Da wir eh nicht eingeladen werden nächstes Jahr, gehen wir trotzdem.
Auf die Gala.
Wir sitzen dann da in diesen hinteren Reihen, trinken Fritz-Limo aus Glasflaschen. Und den Rest dann, Frau Ante, hören wir erst vor Ort.
Wir schauen mal, wir hören mal weiter.
Ab acht Uhr steht sie als Lehrerin vor einer Grundschulklasse. Nachmittags eilt sie zu ihren Schwimmkursen. Am Abend wartet die Arbeit für ihren Verein. Briefe, Anträge, unermüdliches Kämpfen für Spenden.
Juliane ist unfassbar engagiert. Ich meine, die hat einen Fulltime-Job und sagt dann in ihrer Freizeit, ja nicht nur, dass sie mit den Kindern ins Becken geht, sondern macht den ganzen Verwaltungskram noch nebenbei, muss Ausgaben und Einnahmen dokumentieren.
Doch der Schwimmunterricht für die Kinder ist in Gefahr. Die steigenden Kosten und die Inflation übersteigen die Einnahmen. Juliane bangt um die Zukunft ihres Vereins. Es droht das aus.
Wenn wir nächstes Jahr sagen müssten, dass die Kurse schließen, ja, das wäre schlimm.
Wir sind also in einer Situation.
Muss ich ein schlechtes Gewissen haben, weil ich zu meinem eigenen Schwimmunterricht, den ich gebe, nicht eile, sondern einfach mich so schnell hinbewege, wie der Bus halt fährt? Ich könnte ja auch eilen.
Es wird natürlich hier diese Dringlichkeit gezeigt und die Dringlichkeit ist ja bei ihr ist es ja ein Existenzkampf. Also für sie ist das ja entscheidend, das zu machen und es ist ja auch eine extrem wichtige Aufgabe. Und die Politiker aber, die die ganze Zeit sagen, wie wichtig uns das Ehrenamt ist, unterstützen natürlich sie überhaupt nicht dabei.
War der Bundespräsident da?
Der Bundespräsident war nicht da, aber wir haben gleich ein paar andere, die da sind und die werden ja diese Geschichten auch gehört haben und machen dann aber genau eine Politik, die dafür sorgt, dass diese Frau dort verzweifelt ist und diese Schwimmkurs nicht mehr geben kann. Jetzt ist diese Frau auch im Studio zu Gast. Aber zunächst mal gibt es Wichtigeres. Wir hören kurz rein.
Und was jetzt kommt, das ist ein ein großer Fernsehmoment. Es ist das Ende der Fernsehkarriere einer außergewöhnlichen Künstlerin. Ein Weltstar aus Griechenland. Eine junge Frau, die schon 1972, damals für Luxemburg, den Grand Prix de Revision, heute Eurovision Song Contest gewonnen hat mit Apres-Troyes.
Weiß schon jemand, wer es ist? Ah, Wikileon, du hast da sind ja...
Damals für Luxemburg, die einen Start gegangen ist und die über die Jahrzehnte uns einerseits erfreut hat mit unglaublich schöner Musik, uns andererseits aber auch Bayern Herz für Kinder immer wieder großartig unterstützt hat. Ich weiß, das ist auch für sie selbst ein besonderer Moment, denn zum letzten Mal singt sie im Fernsehen. Für euch und für sie liebe das Leben Wikileon Dross.
Ja, das können wir jetzt natürlich aus rechtlichen Gründen leider nicht hören, aber wir können uns vorstellen, wie es war. Du weißt, ich lebe das Leben. Sie hat sich jetzt aus dem Fernsehen verabschiedet. In der Zwischenzeit haben die Leute...
Macht sie nicht den Howard Carpenter? Meinst du?
Also sie hat gesagt, dass sie noch mal Open Air und noch mal da und dort und so, ich vermute wir werden sie noch mal sehen. Jedenfalls, sie sang, sang dann noch von Aber Thank you for the music. Es waren also einige Minuten verflossen. Johannes Bekerner stellt sich wieder zu der Frau, die um ihre Schwimmkurse bankt. Und jetzt Entwarnung.
Ich hab ja im Laufe des Abends schon erklärt, dass ich so ein Knopf im Ohr habe, ist eine komplexe Sendung. Da passiert mal dies und jenes unvorhergesehenes. Da bekomme ich dann Informationen, hab auch Fußballergebnisse, aber warten ja noch einige aus Sportstudio. Deshalb sag ich nicht, wie Gradbach gegen Dortmund gespielt hat. Die Kollegen haben mir gerade aufs Ohr gesagt, dass der Vorstand von Ein Hart für Kinder die Mitteilung machen kann, dass die Schwimmkurse für das gesamte nächste Jahr schon gesichert sind. Danke.
Danke schön, danke.
Es ist unglaublich.
Gute Nachricht für Juliane Heisele und ihr Team und danke natürlich.
Ja, da haben wir mal einen gerettet von den anderen Tausenden, die weggefallen sind. Ist doch ganz schön, dass der Vorstand, der Ein Hart für Kinder AG das jetzt schon mal sagen kann. Andrea Berg denkt auch viel nach jetzt gerade in dieser besinnlichen Zeit.
Und das muss an dieser Stelle mal gesagt werden. Ich hab heute Abend ein bisschen telefoniert auch mit und dass da Menschen 5 Euro spenden, 10 Euro spenden und sagen, ich bin schon in Rente, ich würde gerne mehr. Das ist das Besondere. Diese kleinen, kleinen Steinchen, was alles zusammenkommt. Und dafür möchte ich einfach Danke sagen.
Ja, das ist schön, dass du es sagst. Gemeinsam Großes, gemeinsam Großes schaffen.
Ja, gemeinsam Großes schaffen, aber nicht sozialistisch, sondern hier so ganz eigeninitiativ und eigenverantwortlich.
Und du hast das in voller Länge und einfache Schwierigkeit mitbewegt.
Also ich trinke ja auch dadurch, dass ich ja nicht mehr rauche und zu viel Sport mache, trinke ich ja fast keinen Alkohol mehr. Aber als sich dann so dieses Live-Event hier näherte, hab ich mir gedacht, wie soll ich das durchstehen, wie soll ich mir das angucken? Und ich habe mir dann eine, ja doch gute Flasche Champagner geöffnet und habe sie dann komplett während der Gala unter, aber auch, nein also nicht an einem Tag, sondern am zweiten Tag abends habe ich dann diese Clips geschnitten. Also ich muss erst mal gucken, alle Timed Codes sind so und dann habe ich nochmal geschnitten und da ist jetzt eine Flasche bei draufgegangen. Aber ja, so ist es halt, irgendwie muss man es schaffen. Und wir kommen aber jetzt nochmal zu einer Sache in Deutschland, auch da nochmal interessant, Schuldenbremse etc.
Ja, Kinder brauchen Wärme, Kinder brauchen Zuneigung, Kinder brauchen ein regelmäßiges Essen und es gibt Situationen, Familiengegnen in Deutschland, wo das nicht der Alltag ist, wo das nicht gewährleistet werden kann. Und es ist gut, dass es Einrichtungen gibt, die solche nicht gewährleistet werden kann.
Also viel passiver, da kann man es nicht mehr formulieren....
kehren Verhältnisse auffangen, wie zum Beispiel in Gierskampen im Sauerland, aber auch da ist nicht alles in Ordnung. Auch die Menschen dort brauchen unsere, Ihre, eure Hilfe.
Was ist da los?
Gierskampen, ein Stadtteil von Arnsberg im Sauerland. Seit 1988 gibt es hier den Kinder- und Jugendtreff. Die Türen der Sozialeinrichtung öffnet Melanie Padberg an fünf Tagen in der Woche. 60 Kinder werden im Kinder- und Jugendtreffum sorgt und betreut.
Die Kinder, die hierherkommen, sind mit vielen Problemen konfrontiert, emotional, sozial. Es gibt Migrationsprobleme, Sprachprobleme, Geldprobleme. Wir erleichtern den Kindern das Leben, indem wir mit ihnen Hausaufgaben machen, indem wir mit ihnen lernen für Klausuren, Arbeiten.
Also eigentlich jetzt mal volkswirtschaftlich gesprochen eine riesen Investition, die da getätigt wird, aber vor allem ehrenamtlich, vor allem angewiesen auf Spenden. Wie drastisch die Situation in Deutschland ist, erleben wir dann hier nochmal. Also bei der Zeitung, die die ganze Zeit sagt, wir brauchen nicht mehr Kindergeld und keine Kindergrundsicherung und all das.
Es gibt ein Kreativangebot, ein Spielangebot. Wir helfen, indem wir auffangen, indem wir da sind. Manchmal einfach nur zuhören, in den Arm nehmen. Ein paar liebe Worte.
Erik kommt jeden Tag. Der 12-Jährige wächst ohne Vater auf, seine Mutter ist schwer lungenkrank. Die Einrichtung gibt dem Jungen Halt und ist sein zweites Zuhause.
Ich freu mich, wenn ich hier ins Treff komme. Man kann sehr oft mit Freunden spielen und essen, falls man zu Hause nichts zu essen mag. Das find ich cool.
Melanie Padberg bemüht sich für Kinder wie Erik ein warmes Essen anzubieten. Doch immer wieder gehen der Sozialarbeiterin dafür die finanziellen Mittel aus.
Hier kommen jeden Tag hungrige Kinder und ich wäre total glücklich, wenn ich ein Jahr lang kochen könnte, um ohne mir Gedanken darüber zu machen, wie ich das finanziere.
Kinderarmut in Deutschland, nicht mehr politisch adressiert, sondern nur noch abgeschoben auf die Verrückten, die diese Sendung gucken.
Ein Herz für Kinder will die Sanierung der Einrichtung und das kostenlose Mittagessen für die Kinder ermöglichen. Mit ihrer Spende.
Jeder Euro hilft, damit diese Kinder an diesem Ort weniger Sorgen haben.
Bitte helfen Sie mit.
Wir werden jetzt gleich sehen, welche Politiker dort so sitzen, die also für diese Politik verantwortlich sind, dass diese Kinder kein Mittagessen haben, dass es überhaupt solche Einrichtungen da in privater Hand geben muss. Wir bekommen am Ende noch eine Ehrung dann mit. Da werden zwei Schülerinnen geehrt, die ein Projekt gegen Antisemitismus haben. Auch das ist sehr interessant, weil ja ganz viele solcher Kultur- und Bildungsprojekte gerade zusammengestrichen werden, überall in Bund und Ländern. Und jetzt werden hier aber zwei rausgepickt und die werden dann gefeiert, obwohl man weiß, dass hier schon überall die Axt angelegt wurde. Margot Friedländer, die 103-jährige Holocaust-Überlebende ist auch da, gratuliert diesen Mädchen. Und Annalena Baerbock spricht dann auch zu Ihnen.
Sie, liebe Frau Friedländer, du liebe Margot, du hast einen besonderen Satz geprägt, an den ich, an den glaube ich viele Menschen sehr oft in diesen Zeiten denken. Ich zitiere, es gibt kein christliches, kein jüdisches, kein muslimisches Blut. Es gibt nur menschliches Blut. Dieser Satz ist ein eindringlicher Appell an die Menschlichkeit, an uns alle als Menschen.
Vorgetragen bei der Bildzeitung, deren Haltung wir zum Thema Gaza allzu gut kennen, von einer Außenministerin, die höchstens mal rhetorisch ein bisschen versucht, das einzubremsen, was dort passiert, aber weiterhin liefern lässt. Es ist absurd, aber wir wollen das noch toppen. Und zwar sehen wir jetzt uns die Schlussclips an, die sind aber aus der Mitte. Ich habe nur eine andere Dramaturgie gewählt. Es gibt jetzt ein Duell.
Der für die Prominenten im Saal eher unangenehm ist, weil sie wissen jetzt kommt das, was wir immer Spenden-Roulette genannt haben. Das ist jetzt ein Spenden-Duell. Für Sie und euch zu Hause soll das jetzt schön unterhaltsam werden und das wird es auch. Aber hier im Saal tun die jetzt gleich ganz aufgeregt, so als würden sie wichtig telefonieren. Ich begrüße sehr herzlich Heisel Brugger und Ralf Schmitz. Hallo. Grüß Dich Ralf. Schöner Viertag. Also die Sachlage ist ja einigermaßen schnell erklärt. Ihr sollt jetzt direkt in die Brusttaschen reingreifen, oder das Geld rausziehen. Sonst haben wir immer ein Roulette gehabt, mit einem Comedian, jetzt haben wir zwei Comedians, da haben wir gedacht, machen wir ein kleines Duell. Aber, aber ihr dürft natürlich auch gemeinsame Sache machen.
Also ganz einfach, die Gäste sollen jetzt auch was spenden und die werden jetzt direkt von diesen, sagen wir da einfach halber Comedians angesprochen.
Hallo.
Hallo, ich freu mich.
Der Parteivorsitzende der SPD freut mich.
Also Herr Klingbeier, haben Sie vielleicht ein kleines Sondervermögen für mich?
Es würde mich wahnsinnig freuen.
Haben Sie das in der Tasche? Ich hätt's gern, wie viel würden Sie denn gerne Sondervermögen anlegen?
Hier für einen guten Zweck.
Ich pack mal 500 Euro an.
Was sag ich?
500.
5000 Euro, das ist ja unfassbar.
Unglaublich.
Herr Klingbeier, Sie sind so großzügig.
Ich danke Ihnen.
Wow, 5000 Euro. Oh, Frau Schwesig.
Ich will Kohle von der Manuela.
Ich will Kohle.
Hallo Frau Schwesig.
Hallo.
Ich hoffe, Sie verzeihen mir, dass ich so unverständlich bin. Herr Lauterbar, ich komme noch zu Ihnen, aber erstmal, Frau Schwesig, möchten Sie auch was spenden?
Sie haben doch ein Herz für Kinder.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich bin mit 1000 Euro dabei.
Mit 1000 Euro?
Herr Klingbeier hat 5000 gegeben.
Er ist auch mein Parteivorsitzender.
Bitte?
Also Lars Klingbeier und so, die erzählen doch immer, dass sie ganz viel Geld verdienen und keine Zeit haben, es auszugeben.
Ja, und da wäre das auch eine super Gelegenheit.
Genau. Wieso denkt er im Range 500, wenn es ihm doch nur um Medienzeit geht quasi. Also billiger kriegt er doch gar keine Oma, seufzende Oma Erna zu Hause, als wenn er jetzt hier einfach sagen würde, 15.000.
Also die Schamlosigkeit dieser knickrigen Politiker, die hat mich wirklich nochmal erstaunt. Also es ist ohnehin eine schamlose Veranstaltung. Aber dass man, wenn man dann dort hingeht, nicht wenigstens sagt, gut, ich klotze jetzt mal da, es ist zwar Nonsens, was die da alles aufführen, aber wenigstens nutze ich das für mich. Dass sie das nicht machen, sondern lieber nochmal darüber nachdenken, Mensch, 500 Euro, ja gut, dann wird es ein iPad weniger in diesem Jahr.
Da sehen wir hier Marion.
Da ist, genau, jetzt wird kurz eingeblendet, Marion Horn. Also es ist nicht Claudia Elfenberg.
Ja, wir haben einen neuen Beamer hier in der CASE. Er kann jetzt 4K, ich weiß nicht genau. Der Ring. Von der Bildchefredakteurin, was schätzt ihr?
Ja, ich glaube damit kann man einige Schwimmbäder betreiben, ja. Wir gehen weiter zu einem größeren Spender, Hazel Progau übernimmt.
100.000 Euro.
Dann hab ich ja jetzt schon gewonnen. Aber was soll das, wir können ja zusammenlegen, ich versuch noch mehr rauszuholen, ok? Ich sitz jetzt hier, ich darf mich auch mit dir sprechen. Ich würde jetzt so was machen, das heißt ein Scherz für Kinder. Ich sag jetzt ein paar Witze, die sind eigentlich für Kinder und wenn dein Papa lacht, muss er immer noch 5000 dazuzahlen, ok? Mach ma. Und für jedes Schmunzeln.
Ja, die Witze haben wir uns jetzt erspart heute Abend, aber es geht dann noch ein bisschen munter weiter. Ja, es ist LOL. Jetzt aber hier bei Bild und mit Spenden versehen. Wir gehen wieder zu Ralf Schmitz, Familie Poth.
Von Podcaster zu Podcaster. Warst auch ein Herz für Kinder, was möchtest du spenden?
Ja, können wir uns kurz beratschlagen, weil ich finde. Nee, hatte Zeit genug. Ich kann was spenden, aber vielleicht will mein Sohn was spenden und der Kleine.
Was spendest du?
Also ich gebe, Franjo, wollen wir 5000 geben?
5 mal 4, 20.000, großartig, das ist ja unglaublich. Ich gebe zurück an Hazel, Hazel, du bist wieder dran.
Ja, hei, halt.
Liegt in dieser Methode von Ralf Schmitz für uns eine Heuristik?
Ich glaube, es soll witzig sein. Es ist ein bisschen fremd.
Ja, wenn wir jetzt, also ich überlege, ob in diesem es bewusst falsch verstehen, aber den angesprochen in Verlegenheit bringen, dass er nicht wieder hinter den Versprecher des Versprechens zurückkommen.
Jaja, Sie gehen natürlich ja noch weg mit der Kamera. Ja, man sollte es vielleicht in Talkshows anwenden.
Ja, vielleicht sollte man die ganzen Bundestagsrede-Duelle auch so gestalten.
Ach ja.
Dass, wenn Zahlen in den Raum geworfen werden, es wäre Aufmerksamkeitslogik, genau, wenn in der Aussprache die Bundesregierung so und so Zahlen nennt, dann muss die Opposition mit einer Null mehr darauf reagieren und die aber als selbstverständlich eingepreist und kann nicht wieder aus dem Protokoll getilgt werden.
Ja, also generell, wir haben es irgendwann schon mal angesprochen, wenn Politiker von Millionen sprechen, kann man sofort weghören, weil es dann nicht relevant ist. Also man sollte dann, wenn sie irgendwas von Millionen erzählen, so wie Lauterbach, wir haben noch mal 50 Millionen für therapiebedürftige Jugendliche oder so, dann muss man sagen, ach das ist ja toll, 50 Milliarden, das ist aber ordentlich. So muss man es machen, ja.
Genau. Wir haben was später Zeit. Herr Söder, los, was wollen Sie spenden?
Äh, ja, also...
Oh Gott.
Also, zwei.
Was?
Was zwei?
2.000.
2.000? Herr Söder, ich danke Ihnen. Bisschen knickrig, aber trotzdem vielen Dank. Großartig.
2.000 Euro. Kennt ihr die Familie Söder?
Also erst muss man sagen, Söder selbst wird ja so etwa 240.000 im Jahr als Landesvater, als König von Bayern verdienen, so net war, ja.
Kanzler. Kanzler und König. Also seine Frau, also die Ehe besteht aus einem Vermögen von 270 Millionen Euro, soweit ich weiß. Was bedeutet? Ich als mutiger Argumentierer und Thesensucher vermute ja, dass relativ viel des Überschwangs von Söder beruflich damit zu tun hat, dass er in der Ehe am Abendbrottisch mit seiner Frau auf Augenhöhe kommen möchte.
Ja.
Und deswegen immer wieder die großen Zambord. Genau, genau. Und deswegen immer wieder ein Metier sucht, wo er sozusagen das erreichen kann.
Ja. 270 Millionen. Und man, man, man, also das sag ich, diese Schamlosigkeit der Politik in Deutschland ist unfassbar. Allein dort zu sitzen ist schon ein Skandal, finde ich als Politiker. Und dann 2000 Euro zu spenden. Wir gehen nochmal weiter. Hier noch ein alter Bekannter. Christian Lindner mit Gattin Franka.
Heute mal ein D-Day der anderen Art, das D steht für Donation. Wie viel gibt es denn heute?
Ich meine, ich meine, Sie kennen ja meine berufliche Situation.
Aber Sie konnten ja mal wohl ganz gut mit Geld umgehen. Sind Sie denn beim Spenden auch so ein Fan von Trickle Down? Oben so die Dusche der Spenden und unten können es die Kinder zusammenkratzen. Ich hab Ihre Frau gerade mit dem, Entschuldigung, das war jetzt wirklich nicht geplant, so bin ich eigentlich nicht in den Medien, dass ich Frauen mit Mikrofonen schlage.
Me too. Also ich will jetzt nicht so eine Formel machen wie der Friedrich Merz, sondern ich orientiere mich mal an erfolgreichen Ländern und ich mach auch zwei.
Also auf 2000 Euro von Christian Lindner, jetzt wurde Friedrich Merz schon erwähnt und dieses Highlight habe ich natürlich bis zum Schluss aufgehoben. Friedrich Merz ist mit seiner Frau dort und wird jetzt auch zur Kasse gebeten. Und Stichwort Schamlosigkeit, es geht immer noch mal mehr.
Merz, darf ich Ihren Mann was fragen?
Bitte?
Schön, dann mach ich es trotzdem. Hallo Herr Merz, ich habe ein Angebot für Sie. Wenn Sie ein richtig gutes Angebot an mich machen, jetzt zu spenden für ein Herz für Kinder, dann nennt die Sendung sich ab sofort ein Merz für Kinder. Was sagen Sie?
Also mein Angebot ist Folgendes. Ja? 100 Euro.
Bitte?
Für 100 Euro, für jedes Prozentpunkt, dass wir in der besten Umfrage für die CDU über den Jahreswechsel stehen.
Na ja.
Na ja, hören Sie mal.
Großenartig.
Reinen Sie mal.
Das ist mal, das kann keiner so schnell ausreden. Was ist denn die Untertreibung?
Also wenn wir bei 40 Prozent liegen, sind es 4000 Euro.
Na ja.
Was heißt na ja?
März.
Also hören Sie mal.
Also er knüpft seine Spendenbereitschaft an den Umfrageerfolg der CDU und dann dürfen sich auch die Kinder freuen. Es ist wirklich unglaublich, was da auf uns zurollt für eine Katastrophe. Es ist so unheimlich zu sehen. Und wenn wir ideologisch wissen wollen, wo Deutschland 2024 steht, dann ist das hier. Wir diskutieren nicht über die Schuldenbremse. Wir diskutieren nicht über die wirklichen Bedarfe, die da sind, sondern streuen ein paar Almosen irgendwo hin, um ein paar kitschige Bilder zu produzieren. Am Ende dieser Sendung, den Clip brauchen wir jetzt nicht spielen, das werde ich einfach so reportieren, kommen 23 Millionen Euro zusammen. Dann habe ich heute Mittag mit Ole telefoniert und hab gesagt, ich wollte dich informieren, wir haben 23 Millionen zusammen bekommen. Dann sagt er, wie, wer, wie, ihr sagt ja bei der Spendengala von Bild. Und dann meinte er, ist doch schön, da kann man doch jedem Kind in Deutschland mal ein belegtes Brötchen kaufen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, das ist eine schöne Idee, aber wir haben ja in der Sendung auch noch die Kinder in Burundi, in Tansania und sonst wo. Das heißt, da muss man noch mal gucken, wer was bekommt. Und daran sieht man ja an dieser absurd kleinen Summe und bei diesen absolut großen Problemen, die aber mit Geld zu lösen wären und die gar nicht so groß wären, wenn man mal ein anderes Verhältnis von Staatsschulden, Staatshaushalt usw. hätte. Wie irre wir eigentlich inzwischen unterwegs sind. Es ist wirklich ein Land, das hier eine Verblödungsveranstaltung auf eine Verblödungsveranstaltung öffentlich-rechtlich finanziert einmal im Jahr abfährt, was eigentlich verboten werden sollte. Also es ist wirklich eine... Also wir reden jetzt so viel über Fake-News und alles und über Propaganda und Trolle und Bots und was weiß ich. Das hier ist eine reine Propaganda-Veranstaltung, die alle Zuschauer dümmer machen soll. Und zwar in ganz erhebliche Maße. Und das wird hier hoffentlich nicht geglückt sein, sondern wir wollten ein bisschen Aufklärung reinschaffen. Aber man kann also hier schon mal festhalten, jeder Prominente, jede Politiker, der an dieser Gala teilnimmt, ist ab sofort nicht mehr ernst zu nehmen.
Ja, wir wollen ja März eh nicht ernst nehmen, sondern zerstören. Ich habe hier noch so einen Clip gefunden, ich weiß gar nicht genau woher. Ich glaube, das ist eine Instagram-Beschriftung oder so. Wir hören uns mal kurz an. Friedrich März hat sich in der Kulisse noch gefreut.
Also das war doch eine fantastische Sendung. Was haben wir für Kinderschicksale gesehen? Die sind mir auch persönlich berührt. Und was hat es für eine große Spendenbereitschaft in Deutschland gegeben? Herzlichen Dank an alle, die mitgemacht haben. Und ich will es von meiner Seite auch noch einmal sagen, ich mache 4.000 Euro, spende 4.000 Euro, damit das dann nochmal ein größer Erfolg wird. Eine tolle Sache heute Abend, das war wirklich großartig. Herzlichen Dank an alle, die mitgemacht haben.
So, die 4.000 Euro stehen also jetzt im Raum. Und ich will auflösen. Ich habe ja gechattet, als ich hier an den Tisch kam. Denn Helena Steinhaus schrieb mir, sie wollte wissen, ob ich das, ob hier ein Fehler unterlaufen ist oder so. Denn ich habe heute morgen mehr Familienpolitik als Friedrich Merz, 4001 Euro an sanktionsfrei gespendet. Was bedeutet, die alten Republiken, also ihr nehmt die alten Republiken, versprecht es mir, alle mit nach Hause, ja. Denn es muss ja platt sein, im März kommt ja das neue Buch. Ich möchte also als der Autor, der sich zum Thema Familie äußert in Deutschland platzieren, plus als der bessere Familienpolitiker als Friedrich Merz.
Super.
Meine Spende ist mehr Familienpolitik als Friedrich Merz. Und meine Erwartung ist, aber das ist sozusagen die Hypothese, die wir jetzt prüfen müssen, ob Friedrich Merz das mit Kanzlerschaft noch mal schafft, mich zu überrunden. Ich vermute nicht.
Wir drücken dir natürlich die Daumen, wünschen viel Vergnügen bei der Lektüre. Wenn man nicht nur einen Onkel hat, der Friedrich Merz wählen will, sondern vielleicht auch noch einen Onkel hat, der sagt, bei der Bildgala bin ich immer dabei. Da hat die Andrea Bergmich ermuntert, auch noch mal Spot Money aufzumachen, vielleicht dann den Salon ihm vorspielen oder ihm schenken. Auch das ist ja möglich. Nun erst mal eine gesegnete Weihnacht und wir hören uns dann noch mal am Ende des Jahres.
Alles Gute. So ist es. Haut rein.